you know
if you listen to this show you've heard
me talk about one of my favorite
superheroes especially growing up
watching the old wb
and that static shock you don't know why
this why i like static shock as a
character because it really did tackle
social justice issues but it was like
legit
old school good liberalism about hey be
kind to your neighbors respect people
you know live and let live and all that
stuff and i really like the story
it was the wb version it wasn't the same
as the comic book version for those that
aren't familiar
it's basically some kid who gets bullied
into joining a gang he didn't want to
join
he gets forced down to these docks with
a gang war and then long story short
there's a chemical explosion and all
these gang bangers get super powers and
they're all basically villains
but he was this kid who didn't want to
be there and was mixed up he becomes a
superhero
well in the latest rewrite for the
series
it's now the most absurd storyline ever
he's attending a black lives matter
protest
and the police fire tear gas at the
crowd for like no reason
and the tear gas just instantly gives
everybody super powers welcome to the
era of social justice and comic books
and i i'm sorry you know like maybe we
should have opened with some like very
serious political commentary
but this this this is this is personal
because i've talked about how much i
really like
static shock so we we we we we're
talking about this one
i'm gonna get all triggered but uh we
got a bunch of other really ridiculous
stories we got
uh what was it amazon claimed that their
logo looked too much like hitler
yes and so they had to change it and it
was literally a cardboard box
again welcome to the social justice era
of 2020.
and apparently now bill burr is getting
slammed because he called gina chrono
nice they're claiming like
it was this big defense of gina carano
it's like okay
these people are so desperate for some
kind of weird angle on all this stuff
we're going to get into it and i figured
the the the cultural commentary stuff is
probably
better today anyway because we got ryan
long hanging out he's gonna make fun of
everybody
we do have ryan long in the building
so with the amazon logo uh looking like
hitler
i don't know if you knew this tim but
originally google their original name
for the site was
google's i did not know i was like
where's he going
oh yeah uh he's already writing jokes
[Laughter]
i can't believe they haven't banned you
from just like every social media player
and did you know i don't know if you
know this but social justice they wanted
to change uh himmler
in history books to be her lyrics okay
i can't afford that one yeah when you're
referring your friend
did you write so we're on no
i'm off the dome my friend off my
non-beanie dome
all right and they've changed himmler to
hurler
so earlier when you're yeah when you're
talking about the holocaust and don't
question the numbers
um you you know about the uh the
so-called squared hugs right where they
what the sokol squared hoax no where you
had these these three academics
basically took a chapter out of mineconf
and then
changed the proper nouns to be like
feminist so like
yeah and it got submitted nazis give me
girls but like it didn't say that it
said like the patriarchy is bad and
here's why
and then they submitted it to a journal
and i think that that one got approved
right yeah it did
yeah yeah that was those three because
actually
oh that was one of those guys papers
when they were messing with oh yeah
i do remember that yeah so we're gonna
we're gonna have to talk a whole lot
about uh the amazon
logo and the stupid world we live in and
i don't know they might ban us whatever
because we're talking about amazon and
the stupid things they've done but uh
well yeah you were going on your rant
about mineconf
and before we started tim goes this
episode it's gonna be extra based
yes no no no hold on there was an
australian publisher that banned jordan
peterson's book but not mineconf yeah
like that's how stupid everybody is all
right but we'll we'll say
okay you got all these awesome jokes
written down no i wrote the topics down
that you told me to talk about yeah okay
yeah well you just this was five seconds
ago i didn't come with these papers
yeah i picked them up there's like a
picture of a cake well you said
eight things we're gonna talk about yeah
we're trying to do it sure
it's a very professional operation that
we have here tim where are we at on the
civil war because last time
i came here you said you know you
remember you were like
the civil war is happening and then you
told me you go i
what do you go what are you gonna do
when the civil war happens and i go well
maybe i'll go back to canada you go well
you won't be able to go back to canada
and then you said now you can't go back
to canada and then i was like
yeah a bunch of people stormed into the
capitol building that's true
so i know but i don't i think is the
civil war still happening yeah
absolutely man
i just think people assume civil war
means like two people in uniforms
marching towards each other
right now you've got a call for a
commission they're calling it the one
six commission to track down all of
those responsible for inciting the
insurrection
you've got uh an article today and i'm
sorry a couple days ago nbc
saying republican talk of secession has
become serious and academics are
warning that this time it's for real
texas just uh introduced a bill
that will allow texas to secede from the
union and the gop of texas
endorsed it yeah so look i always say
this
maybe it won't happen maybe yes but you
have the bunker
because yeah i did like i'm very
susceptible the same reason why i was
talking to your crew and they were like
dude you need to get your website more
secure and i was five seconds ago i'm
like i need to hire a team
like i've literally left tim's house
before being like i need a gun i need a
bunker
he got me a jazzed up dude i was telling
other people
i went back to new york i'm telling
people i'm like they're coming for us
man
what are they saying now after the the
storming of the capitol who what whoever
who's saying
the people you're talking to you're like
tim was saying this stuff are they like
whoa what's going on
well i think that uh most people in new
york
probably his take were those guys were
bad news and we're glad we got the
orange guy out of the power right yeah
but as far as whether the still civil
war is happening well so
it's it's fifth generational warfare
it's it's information it's propaganda
it's manipulation but there is low tier
violence across the country
when you know look there's just been
more than one instance where
like i was saying people assume it's
going to be people in uniforms marching
towards each other that's
that's like 200 years ago you know what
i mean we're not we're not that kind of
people anyway it's not what happened so
what happens when the civil
like what what are examples of the
things that they do so this is your bank
accounts delete you from the internet
like that kind of stuff
strip you of resources so like this is
actually based on academic research that
came out of uc san diego
where they talked about how it will be
removing people's ability to speak
so that the political narratives are
dominated by only one faction
yeah that way political so if you have
two factions two parent factions that
are fighting over control of a
government
and you strip one of the faction's
ability to communicate then the only
thing
you you basically isolate each
individual so they can't form
any kind of cohesive response yeah it's
so
it perhaps uh you know i would say war
might might lead people to thinking like
in the past but there was a princeton
professor who said we are in a cold
civil war and this guy's a democrat he's
a lefty i think yeah there's a couple
different
civil wars going on there are a couple
different cold wars happening in unison
probably it's true it's a
war within a war within a war so i think
gender war
yeah well all this stuff is part of like
the same idea but again i think
the problem is when you have midwits you
know midwid is
yes when you have these people hear the
phrase civil war they're like smart
enough to engage
but they're not smart enough to
understand the future
well it's also and predict there's also
i probably an element of
when you use those words to you get to
dismiss the fact that it's happening the
same way that
they do with conspiracies like even you
know it's always like oh pete they think
that there's these pedophiles in the
pizza shop or whatever
you know and then people go all these
crazy and you're like i mean they've had
nine pedophile conspiracies that have
got uncovered
recently i mean epstein it's really it's
really interesting
there's like you know that epstein is
what makes people kind of go crazy when
they see this and they want answers and
they don't get them
we'll get into all this yes this is a
very long stock invention uh
so what okay so let me let's do we got
we got to introduce the other people
i'd rather not just i would rather not
i'd rather talk
about ryan it is not your show i'd
rather talk about me
so listen
i'm here from new york it's very busy
right now saturday night
it's not set it's not that what uh
guys we are here with uh my co-host ian
crossland thank you ryan yeah yeah
thank
you
thank
you
thank
you
thank
you thank you thank you super chat any
questions for me or ian i just i want to
talk about social justice infiltrating
comics because i think maybe
captain america was like social justice
of the 40s yeah it was all about
fighting nazis propaganda
war propaganda is that the history of
comics all together is is just
propaganda and i mean everything is
right also i'm excited to talk about the
war within the war within the war the
cold war
the the the war for your mind and your
soul that's global
chinese maybe in the american government
the the the national
fight and then this the soul your own
personal war against your neighbor
whether or not you're gina carano man i
mean i'm in a personal war against my
name
the gina carano thing is a really good
example of of this you know
fifth generational warfare it's not the
biggest thing in the world it's just a
grain of sand in the heat
the bigger conflict is probably at law
and stuff like that but gina chrono
posted an image saying don't demonize
your neighbors she didn't compare
anybody to republicans or to jews or
anything like that
and they just they just nuked her so but
we'll talk about it let's let's let's
lydia's pressing button yeah we got a
script this guy's right yeah we gotta
get off
he's super ready i don't want to get in
ryan's way i'm afraid i will get run
over but i'm here in the corner pushing
but
you work for me now yeah it's true i do
i have a new boss
same as the old boss it turns out i have
a super chat from one of our people
uh tim how many times have you said the
gamer word
oh are you talking about pewdiepie
you're trying to get us in trouble you
know okay all right all right
okay okay ladies and gentlemen canceled
i'll just tell you i'll just tell you
what i'll just tell you what go to
timcast.com
become a member because i can only
imagine what's going to happen when we
do
the exclusive you know behind the
paywall segment where we're
going to say he's going gonna get us
banned from everything even though it's
behind the pay wall it's just all the
gamer words
ryan there's more than one the gamer
words
we're gonna find all right all right all
right let's let's let's i gotta read
this story
all right this one this one is near and
dear to my heart yes when i saw the
story i was like i don't want to talk
about comics and i read it and i was
like
[Laughter]
bounding into comics says dc comics
retcon sees
static received powers during black
lives matter protest
okay first i was just like all right
well you know
it's a modern retelling of a comic book
story black lives matter can be relevant
to this
and then i read the the the panels they
include
and i'm just like this is really bad
it's really good
so uh i don't know if i need to
necessarily read the uh
let's read a little bit they say a
recent retcon to the origin story of the
dc comic superhero static
real identity virgil hawkins has changed
the inciting incident that grants him
superpowers from a gang war
to a black lives matter protest okay
there is so much wrong with this
i'll i'll need to actually read the
comic to give you a better breakdown
but let me just explain something in the
original in the original comic
he's basically he's a good kid but he's
being bullied
he gets a gun and he shows up at this
gang war and he wants to take out his
bull he wants to kill his bully
but he decides he can't do it he starts
crying and he throws the gun into the
water
but then the police seeing a gang war
you know people are trying to kill each
other
fire and experimental tear gas which
create cause some crazy reaction they
call the big bang and then also and all
these gang bangers get superpowers
well guess what these are not good
people right
turns out they become super villains but
this kid who was down there who actually
was an okay kid just mixed up in some
bad stuff
ends up becoming a hero in the in the
more in the later version
the more recent version it's the stall
all still pretty old
the wb cartoon static shock he basically
gets pressured into joining
he doesn't want to join so i thought
that was a really awesome way to deal
with issues that
i know exactly what that was like
growing on the growing up on the south
side of chicago i knew people
who were surrounded by people and gangs
who were like are you joining or not you
have you know you have to join you live
in our area
and then it's called veed you get veed
in you get violated
and so what they do is they would beat
the crap out of these kids who are like
14 or 15 force them to join gangs
one dude went to prison because what
they want to do is they want to get a
minor
give them a gun and say go and kill our
enemies because you'll get out in four
years because they can't hold you until
you're 18. so
when i saw this show i was like wow
that's that's clever right
it actually gets to you know like real
issues that i think affect young people
they don't want to get mixed up in this
stuff it addressed social justice issues
in a really cool way
and it actually told an interesting
story there's a chemical explosion
the people who are there happen to be
mostly gang bangers
mostly become super villains now this
kid who gets mixed up in it
he's like i didn't want to be here in
the first place i'm going to do good i'm
going to try and be better
my question now is in the in the new
version
they're all at a black lives matter
protest right and for no reason
the police start shooting them with tear
gas so in this comic
the cop says you know who do they think
they are
turn around and get back to school or be
arrested for truancy and then someone
yells
stop killing innocent people and we will
someone holding a sign that says she was
sleeping
fine then let him fly says the cop as
they start shooting this tear gas at the
crowd
almost instantly one dude's skin starts
melting off
and the cop is like is that kid's face
melting and then all of a sudden they
all have super powers
so like this is the story the cops fire
tear gas had a random group of black
lives matter protesters
they all get through powers i got i got
a question about this where the villains
come from
well i guess that'd be the police in
this scenario sting copeland all of them
well no i mean they are they are they
are portraying the cops of the bad guys
but it's gotta be right
but what i mean is the cops in the in
the uh comic are wearing gas masks
in the original version it was gang
bangers getting gassed yeah
and so naturally many of these people
are not good people become villains well
what do they say what do they say the
villains do come
from i don't know it just it just says
he's like i got powers
but hold on here's the funny thing he
says here's what says he goes uh uh
i don't i don't know what the first
panel is it's just him waking up saying
which made me stronger stronger than i
could ever imagine then electricity
bursts from his eyes
now i could get revenge on all the
bullies who picked on me
who pick on everybody but it turns out
they have powers too
and it's three white dudes and it's like
blonde
and they're bullies one guy's like
shirts ripping he's all ripped one guy's
fist is on fire they have the protesters
too
and i'm just like essentially three biff
from uh back to the fifth yeah
but does this mean they were also
protesting for black lives matter
yeah why were they there because they
wouldn't be there like protesting
against it
oh but yeah maybe that's it they were
there you know
they needed antifa there that were also
violent protesters that then became
villains but instead they they framed
the cops they had all bullies lives
matters
i wonder if like the angle they're going
for is that the bullies are bad guys and
they're like we're gonna rob this bank
and then he's like you're at the black
lives matter protest too but you're a
villain well well hold on we may be
villains but we all agree black lives
matter all right
right so that's the angle they're going
for well of course the villains were
there even the villains agree
yeah it's almost like they chose this uh
topic but it was so sensitive that they
had to sort of uh
illogically decide kind of the rest of
the plot line
i just i'm just a train wreck i should
have i should have expected
that you know this is the angle they
would go but it really does feel
like cheap i'm not trying to be mean to
black lives matter or anything i mean
you know we've talked about them quite a
bit i've been critical of
over the riots but like you one of the
biggest problems with
star wars latest iterations and like
captain marvel and a lot of these new
comics
is that it's just really cheap writing
it's not clever it's not good it's not
interesting it's just really obvious
like it's a dude sitting there with his
eyes half closed and he's like i don't
know he's a black lives matter protest
or something
just write it down and sell it you know
like it used to be
that whenever you're getting propaganda
period
the hope is that it's good enough that
you'll take your propaganda like i'll be
watching certain shows
and you can kind of tell when it's
really getting into that stuff and
they're trying to sell you something you
go okay
and then there's another one where the
show sucks and you're like hey there's
12 characters and 11 of them are gay and
you're like
this isn't good enough for how much
you're shoving this down my face
so i think the problem is yeah it's it's
like anything in any art
or songs you know anything you're
listening to it's like
you get to give me a teaspoon of
propaganda per good amount of
entertainment
right right and then i think that they
are tipping the scales where the
the propaganda levels are out of the out
of the
ballpark but i mean like even so i bet
the
the argument from the left will be the
original static shot cartoon
was very much social justicey but it was
the
like the liberal kind i mean i mean like
philosophically liberal
where it was just hey man don't be mean
to somebody for no reason don't be
racist
now it's just like this this seems like
what do they call it um
they call it rainbow washing when you
just make something you know lgbtq to
sell a product
it's kind of like social justice wash
and they're like oh that is that's
static so just
i think there's probably so much
logistical things too it's the same
thing that happened with
you know recently we were talking about
even this is on amazon i'm sure you guys
cover like potato and all that stuff but
it's like
they basically were like oh there's an
easy way to kind of get clicks and this
your new advertising campaign comes in
and they go yo all you have to do is
this
but then now even on that side they go
hey you didn't do it right and then the
other side gets mad at them so
i think in a lot of ways the the like
easy bucks to be made of social justice
are becoming harder and harder
so you know what i mean they're like oh
we'll do this everyone will like it
you got extra extra virgin olive oil you
got extra virgin olive oil you got
virgin and you got olive oil
and so it's like the very last drop yeah
they're trying to squeeze out the last
drop of money that you can get from
you know saying you've got the right
opinions so i think when you do this
it's like i think that you probably end
up making a lot of decisions and choices
based on things other than what makes
sense for your plot probably
have you guys seen the new craft movie
no it's called the craft right i think
you've talked about that yeah are the
witches
yeah the witches bro if you want
material you should watch the craft
yeah i'm progressive i only support male
witches because i think that
well you'll love it because there's one
in the movie yeah of course
they basically i'm a spoiler alert for
anybody who plans on seeing this movie
they there's a bully and they cast a
spell to turn him gay i guess
i think that's what happens and then he
gets murdered for being gay or they
didn't cast a spell and he's like it was
a spell right
you know his girlfriend is like what
happened he's freaking witches man
why are you blowing a dude have you
heard of witches
now everybody's listening will have a
clever excuse if they ever need to use
them
they don't know about witches
[Laughter]
but his dad's a witch yeah his dad's a
male witch yeah
so so uh anyway the witch is like
breaking to his house
and then like they steal some of his you
know man
what which i call it reproductive fluids
and then cast a spell on him
to make him nice and then he like
becomes a gay i guess so then his dad
has to kill him or something
the whole movie it's not a movie yeah i
mean fair enough your dad does have to
kill you yeah
it goes without saying the movie is the
movie is basically just like
uh awoke psa and i'm watching it like
waiting for a story to happen and it's
not there
yeah but i mentioned that but there's
also i was watching waiting for the gay
sex scene and it never came either so
both of us were disappointed
yeah yeah no yeah yeah so you're
disappointed for other reasons there's
another movie called spiral
and this one is oh man we i think we
talked about this in one of the tim cass
segments
so you know what shutter is at shutter
like
shuu ddr it's a it's a a subscription
service for horror shows and movies no i
love hor i love horror it's like my
favorite genre i love
you know the uh what is that what does
that move in the cold game and the
others
yeah i think that that movie is awesome
that movie is great and i love old 80s
movies i just watched the stuff have you
ever seen it
no it's where people start eating trash
out of the ground
but then it turns out it's like you know
a lot of funks
so this shutter has this film called
spiral and
it starts with an interracial gay couple
who have a daughter and then they move
to a new town no i'm fine
i don't care about that i don't i don't
care about static being a black lives
matter protest i care about the story
making sense
how are you going to have super villains
if like how are the bullies were they
the black lives matter protests like
what's going on
i guess right so anyway i'm watching
this movie and i'm like
i didn't i didn't really think twice
about the interracial gay couple being
you know
the characters i was just like it's 20
20 man you know i was like whatever
but then very early on you get a glimpse
of what the movie is
i'm just gonna spoil the whole movie for
everybody if you're a subscriber to
shudder
well you know too bad witches witches
it turns out switches again there are
immortal white people
who explain that they choose minority
and marginalized families on purpose
to frame for murders so that they can
sacrifice them for immortality
and then in the end the bad guy is like
there will always be people to fear
and no one will ever believe you
and i'm like you gotta be kidding me
dude like like you said you can give me
a teaspoon of propaganda for every
you know every cup of entertainment i
get that was the whole thing was
propaganda i liked uh
the 100 i like i honestly thought that
show was kind of good but
by the end they so everyone's a lesbian
right
one of those shows like all the all the
everyone all the leaders are women and
they're all lesbians
and all of the women are the best
fighters and it's sort of like a sci-fi
thing but then they give the backstory
and they just came on a spaceship and
there's like
they don't give you any logistical
reason why
in this world the women like it's not oh
they're like amazonian women it's just
like normal women
and for some reason the women are better
fighters than guys they don't explain
you go okay whatever
yeah you just have to be like i want i
watched these fight scenes better be
sweet dude i watched a really good
there's a video explaining why captain
america
and captain marvel are like totally
different like captain america is good
everyone loved it captain marvel like
people kind of like groaned at it and
kind of accepted it and they explained
that one of the issues is
you know like early on in captain
america they explained to you
steve rogers captain america is a weak
guy he's weak but he's willing to stand
up he's a scrawny dude getting beat up
outside of a theater
and it establishes yeah they have to
give you that like establish your world
i'll believe your world but you just
have to give me an explanation even if
the explanation's stupid they go
oh he stepped in a puddle that gave him
this you go okay like you just right
otherwise you go it doesn't make sense
but your context but in this in this
context what they're basically saying is
you know who steve rogers is he's not
the strongest guy
but he's willing to stand up and defend
himself no matter what
with and then he eventually gets
superpowers and then you see this guy of
really good moral character who wants to
protect people
now is powerful and says i'm gonna do
the right thing whereas captain marvel
is
she's always strong she's always been
the best and the man like there's a guy
yeah there's no they've completely uh
removed themselves from any hero's
journey
all of these like roman power movies
basically became steven seagal movies
where there's no adversity
like they start out and she's just like
oh ready to kick some ass and then she
goes beats up everyone and then
you know it's like there's there's no
even point where she wasn't going to
potentially make it
this is this is the problem i guess with
modern
the modern version of i guess gen z
storytelling it's probably millennials
who are writing these comments but think
about this
if if you've got let's take a look at
the black lives matter narrative right
that they're doing a comic where they're
like telling the cops you're killing
innocent people
well that's a gross oversimplification
of what's happening the cops are
immediately the bad guys who fire on
them for no reason
in captain marvel she's actually the bad
guy
in in the beginning of the movie some
guy in a motorcycle tells her to smile
so she steals his clothes and his
motorcycle and presumably just leaves
him like nude in a parking lot wow
yeah that's like when that happened i
was kind of like dude i don't want to
root for this character
some guy made a snide comment so she
robbed the reason for it
like i i find this even when i'm writing
stuff and especially when i was like
doing more traditional stuff
there is this thing of like you're not
supposed to say this about this person
you're not supposed to say this but this
but like
so if you're gonna make people
protagonists they need
you know bad qualities and good
qualities but there's this sort of thing
like if you're going to write a woman
they're like oh we'll make her a shitty
and you're like
well you can't make women bad like
that's bad for women we're just going to
make a
woman character and like yeah here's our
hero she's like can't critically think
uh you know no you're like what do you
mean you can't make we need strong women
characters with no flaws
well that's that's well that's not
really a good story that there's no
flaws
think about do you see what happened
with wmx in the other day no but how
about that for uh
that's how i get my superpowers is i'm
at the women's march
when some yes i love it yeah so when the
police fire tear gas at them yes
for no reason police fired tear gas at
the women but it didn't i didn't need it
it turns out
well they thought they fired tear gas
turns out they were just already crying
oh my gosh the whole women and it was
their it was their love for the fellow
man that granted them superpowers
yeah yeah that's what it was so i'll
tell you the one last thing that this is
a joke but i said that
how what happens at the women's march is
they all march from one side of the city
and halfway through they forget
something and go back
and that's it they all forget something
and at the end it was their superpowers
and i donated money to the women's march
i hope they find a cure okay
okay all right so do you see that you
see you see the whimx
with twitch no tell me about this twitch
put out a video
where they were like we we want all
whimx in to be
supported oh yeah yeah no of course and
the left got really mad it was like yeah
they got fired up and then they had
issued an apology being like are bad
yeah we didn't realize that you know
calling you whimsics and we thought it
was inclusive
you're making this very hard to pander
to you right now but think about that
think about they're like okay we're
gonna make a movie we want to get
feminists and women to come watch so
let's do the hero's journey
and they're going through the script and
they're like let's make it very much
like captain america everyone loved that
one
well we can't make her weak correct like
steve rogers was a scrawny weak guy in
the beginning
okay we'll just have her be strong but
how do we then establish
her journey amnesia she's always strong
but she has amnesia that's what they did
that's the moment
that's the movie and then they do this
thing where they're like okay what's her
conflict
her killings heal five thousand dollar
purses
i think that's the only that's her
tonight the men keep telling her to
control her emotions
oh i'm not kidding that's the movie
she's always strong
she gets amnesia and the guy says you're
too emotional and at the end
she like uses her emotions and says
something like i can do whatever i want
i guess
but so the point i'm making is they
could not make a flawed female character
out of fear that they'll get ripped
apart by the woke left like
look you say wimmix and thinking you're
pandering to them and you're actually
insulting them
there's no right way to address it i
think the trans people got kind of fired
up about that one too they did
understand well count dankula had
probably the best response
he said imagine fighting your whole life
to transition and to be considered a
woman
and then these woke corporations just
come out and tell you you're not
like and then all these woke leftists
were like dankula redemption arc
and he's like no i've always felt that
way like yeah acting like it's a
different opinion but then he did show
the second video of his dog
the black lives matter one yeah it was
it was worse than that i love that one
yeah
let's let's let's let's just jump to the
next segment where we can talk about the
ramifications of
social justice stuff and this will this
will be probably a little bit more
outside
your wheelhouse but i'm sure you'll
still be able to make fun of them ryan
so over in virginia the new law
banning police from pulling over
virginia drivers solely for certain car
safety violations
officers can also not stop people if
they smell marijuana so in virginia they
passed new legislation's taking effect
monday
so i believe i believe it was it's
already taken effect yeah i think so
we'll make it harder for authorities in
virginia to pull over drivers
several minor infractions while still
illegal can no longer be the primary
reason police stop you while you're
driving
these include certain defective
equipment objects dangling from your
rear view mirror loud exhaust
tinted windows and smelling marijuana to
name a few an expired inspection or
registration sticker can only get you
pulled over however
it has to be at least four months late
the legislation lists more changes
here maybe we can pull these up and see
what they see what they are going on
social justice advocates say
this is a win i think it's a first step
it's a huge first step said brad haywood
founder and executive director of
justice forward virginia haywood said
these violations have long been used to
stop people from drug investigations
and disproportionately target people of
color well
i think it's it's it's i'm not going to
read this whole law i don't know there's
a whole bunch of crazy stuff in it
i do think it's kind of absurd that cops
can't pull people over now because
the original proposal was it was like
black lives matter protesters were
saying they just pull over people of
color and they use it as excuses
i think cops use things as excuses i've
had cops pull me over
i had a cop pull me over once and as
soon as like i roll the window down
i put my you know my keys and wallet on
top of the dash
i put my hands on the steering wheel i
turn the radio off he walks up and the
first the cop does is go excuse me oh
whoa he's i smell marijuana and i'm like
i'm sorry yeah that's my cologne i'm
like i'm
no i i i just got off work i was wearing
my work jumpsuit from o'hare
and i worked a double shift my car was
full of taco bell wrappers which is
maybe why he thought he could get away
with accusing me of smoking pot
[ __ ] magnet you and oh totally the
whole no you don't understand
when i mean full i mean like the ground
and the chair
was a mound of taco bell right there
no but he pulled me over and he any and
he was like i smell pot and i was like
i don't smoke and he's like out of the
car i got coughed they searched my
vehicle and tried planting pot in my car
yeah no joke so i see stuff like this
and i'm like i understand
but it's also kind of crazy that someone
could literally be smoking pot and the
cop can't pull them over well if they
see it i think they still can right
i guess yeah just if they smell
marijuana but i mean come on if like
i i grew i grew up in chicago people
smoked pot all the time and they what
where they call it clambake
or hot boxing boxing a little bit of
both it depends on where you're from in
the country
clambake or hot boxing is when they
close all the windows and then just the
whole thing gets fogged up
and i'm like okay so the cop can't see
anything it's just smoke right
so when they open he says i saw smoke
look like what kind of smoke was it
well they can probably bust you if
you're there and they walk up to the
window now they just can't stop you so
if but when is a cop gonna smell it
driving as you drive by that's probably
not very common
it can happen bro you've never driven
past a car and you're like whoa
those guys are going at it dude dude you
can see people driving in the smoke
coming out of there definitely see it
yeah yeah no no but the bigger picture
here is are we getting to the point
where
the sensitivities over the social
justice stuff are getting the point
where like a cop can't pull someone over
for literally breaking the law
it's obviously when you go to the
extremes at any of these things i always
used to say like in comedy
because essentially there's like a war
on noticing things
you know like because it's a you know
good point a big thing that you don't
talk about is like oh you know women
kind of do this more
guys kind of do this more and you go oh
it's interesting that black guys kind of
do this or like you know whatever it is
like that's
base level but noticing things that and
then kind of
that's funny right pattern discernment
yeah literal yeah literally
noticing patterns in your brain right
and you're admitting to being a bigot
yeah exactly right
so yeah there's there's a it's a war on
noticing things where you go there
but it's it's so manufactured and it's
so fake and so this is what happens when
it gets these things get taken to their
extreme
but i agree with you that the cops do do
all that stuff put it this way i used to
have really long hair
like this guy and i i cut my hair
and i've never been pulled over since i
cut my hair and when i had long hair
like him honey
dude when i had long hair like him twice
at the airport i was searched my entire
bag searched
i was pulled over for no reason lots of
different times
and since i've cut my hair 10 years ago
never happened again so
you know they're one of course they do
and i've had
cops do all sorts of crazy stuff but
this is crazy let me read this there's a
quote why should they be allowed to
investigate people based on hunches when
they have no evidence
why don't we expect them to actually get
probable cause for drug position
or gun position before they pull a call
car over hayward said
i read that and i'm like that's kind of
like oxymoronic a hunch
that's what probable cause is like a
reasonable you know i
like you have a reasonable well probable
cause is that
you have a reasonable suspicion that
someone is doing something could be a
hunch
right it sounds like a hunch yeah you
know it's one of those things like a
reasonable doubt
yeah you go most people for a lot of the
problems we go
do you think it's bad that you know
there's these bad cops pulling people
over and you go
yeah and i think most people go that's a
problem you go what's the solution they
go cops can't pull anyone else over and
you go oh no that's not what it is
that's totally reasonable
i wasn't saying that and you're like
road pops for the boys
because the boys are rocking out on the
way to the cottage
i i think you know i would we need a
visual representation of this idea
where it's like exactly what you said
you know it's kind of it's kind of bad
that like
what a statistic like you know one in a
certain number of cops will do something
defund all police abolish all the cops
you know what i mean it's always the
logical extreme of
okay we don't want this and i i think so
many things like with the censorship and
everything it's the same problem you go
most people if me and you are having a
conversation they go that was kind of
mean what that guy did you know and we
go yeah that was
you know what was that guy doing at this
party calling that girl this or whatever
right
right and then yeah and then and then
he's like i agree and then the next day
you found out he's like
petitioning for laws that it's illegal
to be mean at the party and you go well
that's not
right you know people want to legislate
their what they consider their morality
you know what i mean
it's like people want the government to
be legislating their moral principles
and i think that's kind of we don't all
have the same moral principles
right right so this actually happened
lansing this is uh i'm assuming this is
michigan right yeah
they pass something similar say new
guidelines lansing police won't
won't stop drivers solely for minor
infractions
they say the new guidelines are
consistent with the department's goal of
protecting citizens rights while
eliminating any aspect in further
otherwise of bias-based traffic policing
practices
so so let me get this straight you've
got this happening in michigan you got
it in virginia
they're saying cops can't pull you over
if your license plate is expired
all right that's that's that's kind of a
problem i mean you register your car for
a reason you're paying taxes you're
contributing
so the issue i have here well i'm i
wonder if the libertarians are all
cheering
there's but there's also the other
element of
making you know the most aggressive laws
to force you into that position where
you go well i don't know
like you're all of a sudden pro cop yeah
and then they go look at this guys like
blue lives matter dude and they kind of
it's like they pick these extreme
positions that everyone's like
i mean that's a little crazy and you're
like what you know they do
it's like with all the issues the issue
now is basically
all they're really saying is you don't
have to get your license plate renewed
for four months for four months so
that's actually kind of fine i guess you
get a four-month buffer then what's the
point of putting the sticker on your
plate
why bother going and getting a renewal
if you know you can't get in trouble for
it you can't get pulled over for it
could be like a covid like
we're not going to make just like a
little buffer that in case people can't
afford to get the lessons right
see that the point is cops are supposed
to just give you a warning
so well not supposed to but i think i
think they should be supposed to
so when when my plate expired on my on
my car when i was like 19 the one full
of taco bell rappers
it was a different time yeah i got
pulled over the clam magnet
yeah yeah totally dude you have no idea
when those ladies saw the taco bell they
were like
oh is that taco bell no no they were
like i'm about to unwrap my tacos the
amount of rappers in your car must be
clearly ten thousand dollars worth of
taco bell oh this guy's
balling dude this guy's a taco bro
i got the rappers to talk about nobody
are you tim bell
when i got pulled over the cop walked up
to the car and he said
uh your plates are expired and i was
like oh
real i was like i don't know man i'm
like i was like i just
just got the car i have no idea how this
works anyway no problem just go get it
fixed dude
i didn't have anything burritos today i
can't deal with this right now i was
like officer
boy too much taco bell it's coming no no
he was just he just walked up and he was
like
get it updated and i was like yeah all
right thanks man and then i got pulled
over again like a week later
and the same thing happened cop walked
up and he goes you know license
insurance and he goes your uh your
license plate's expired
and i said straight up i was like uh
yeah man i just had a warning from a cop
and you know he told me to get
registered so i went to the thing i got
it
filled out i guess it's coming soon
anyone okay have a nice day i suppose
that's the kind of story
where you hear these progressive
leftists being like when i got pulled
over for an expired plate they gave me a
warning or
when i was going 120 in a 35 school zone
they gave me a slap on their
speeding is different yeah they're like
i killed a guy and i no one even knows
yet when a black guy does it and you go
what you killed who knows like if if you
get pulled over for speeding and your
license is expired then you're in
trouble
in my opinion yeah if your license
plate's expired but if you just
are the speeding is dangerous speeding
can kill people that's
i think you should always the cops
should be very diligent about pulling
over people for speeding
so i think like i don't know you made
the point really well it's you say hey
is it kind of bad that sometimes cops
pull people over for bs reasons you're
right no
cops should be able to pull anyone over
that's like a really extreme crazy thing
but the the issue i have a lot of these
stories from a scientific perspective
is when like lived experience is not
science
you know did were you following the
smith college thing that happened
recently
will smith went to college yeah will
smith
they're rebooting back to school with
rodney dangerfield it's with this time
no no so there's a school where there
was this black woman and she was in an
unauthorized area of the university
eating
so the janitor was told if anybody goes
in there just call the security
security got called they went there and
they asked her the cop was just like you
know what's going on and she was like
i'm eating and she's like shaking and
filming him
and he was like oh okay you know sorry
to bother you just you know we're
supposed to have anybody in here but you
it's fine if you're here
and then she claimed it was this big
like super racist moment
yeah so the new york times wrote an
article saying it was a moment when her
lived personal truth was at clash with
the facts
the new york times actually wrote that
so the problem i have is
how do we know you know if like
someone's
when someone says i get pulled over for
no reason it's like the difficult thing
is
there's no control right we can't send
one card on a rope the same cop
no and then with like with like an asian
driver and then a black driver and a
white driver and then see which one gets
pulled over
and there's multiple factors like some
girls think that i'm like you know
like an asian girl or whatever and she's
like oh you're being mean to me because
i'm asian and i'm actually just being
mean to her because she's a woman
right you never really know right you're
just trying to find ways to be offensive
and no matter what point you make right
yeah you're like let me offend as many
people as possible on this show
uh i you have to understand when i did
uh
say that i meant womex and
they say it's pronounced uh the x is uh
pronounced
you're supposed to it's the two arms and
uh there's a suck it under
that's the under contact that's the
subtext they don't want you to know that
well apparently
that's the x factor the words offensive
to everybody sector so everybody's
offended by it
but no you can't like if you're
everyone's had
those experiences and you go and it kind
of goes to why i mean
i was saying the other day that like
there's a lot of people that
they're fox news when it's uh agrees
with them and their their cnn when it
doesn't like for example if you say
someone will go
okay that different racial groups have
different crime more right and they'll
be like obviously that's because of the
system and you go okay well then why do
guys
go to jail less than women and they go
well that's because women are less
violent and you go
right you legitimately switch between me
and fox news and cnn based on whether
it's the
group that you care about because guys
are more violent yeah well exactly right
i mean and you go obviously a lot of
these things are a mix of they're all
multi-variable things
but nuance is difficult and takes a lot
of energy and oh it's not very
good for activism it's not allowed yeah
it's like there there's
like legit scientific conversations are
very very hard to have on youtube
because they'll try and get you banned
for talking about
actual scientific studies they'll argue
the studies themselves were fake or
bigoted or paid off and it's like
so which one which paid off study do you
pick i guess like yeah it's all
political
i kind of have that that same mentality
sometimes when it's like oh you can't
talk about this because you're a man or
whatever whatever it is
and i go all right give me a list of
things that i'm not allowed to talk
about and let's avoid those subjects
cause i'm not about to hear you like
just listen to you speak and be like
zip it up that's basically what they do
yeah you go oh you're not allowed to
talk on this one's like i guess let's
move on then because that doesn't sound
very interesting to me
let's let's let's jump to the story
about uh about amazon and cancel culture
and uh my friends uh thank you for
tuning in to the show tonight and i'm
pretty sure this segment is gonna get us
in trouble
because the internet is stupid it's very
very stupid
and just take a look at this story from
the new york post amazon tweaks app
icon after comparisons made to hitler
what psychotic person
hold on hold on i'm not saying the
people who thought this black cardboard
box would tape on
hitler are psychotic i'm saying the
person who worked at amazon
saw someone complaining that your box
looks like hitler
so they immediately rushed to the
graphic department said quick change it
change it
that person's a psychopath yes they
should have been like when crackpots on
the internet start screaming that the
moon is made of cheese we don't
entertain them
and write books about it and make sure
they get it we say can we get a picture
of it
of the yeah can we get a picture oh yeah
it's up right now okay
you just can't see it you want to see it
yeah yeah i want to see it
it kind of does look like killer it's
going to pull up on your phone i can't
spin it nope nope it's the hair we're
looking at
that yeah yeah look oh because i thought
to me that looks like michael jordan
when he had the hitler mustache that's
why
michael jordan had hitler you guys don't
remember that no
i know you think i'm joking because i've
been saying a lot of fake things this
episode
but michael jordan he did a whole
commercial campaign and everyone's like
why do you have a hitler mustache oh my
gosh yeah i was like a thin mustache
oh he's no you're thinking of when he
had the lip like the cool black guy like
where it's just like this
line of hair no he's just like right in
the middle dude oh wow he was just like
[ __ ] you know screw it i can bring it
back dude i'm michael jordan and if
anyone could
it's true all right well check it out i
see michael jordan but
so the new york new york post writes
amazon has changed its new smartphone
app logo after critics said the earlier
incarnation was a dead ringer for adolf
hitler
a dead ringer a dead ringer a dead
ringer no joke they literally did look
at this
one guy let me let me see if i can pull
i'm trying not to make a few different
jokes right now too keep it in ryan okay
so alex alex is
alex hearn is a uk tech editor for the
guardian
and he tweeted lmao i completely missed
that amazon quietly tweaked its new icon
to make it
look less like hitler and then some
responded well i mean to see hitler's
mustache in a rip scotch tape
one must really think of hitler all the
time because i still don't see
all that result exactly the internet
internet is too exaggerated and
everything
and someone responded it's not just rip
scotch tape it's a ripped scotch tape
that has a similar shape
and is right on top of a smiling mouth
looks like a happy little cardboard
adolf to me
somebody responded a really funny tweet
they said yes yes the image of the
smiling happy-go-lucky hitler yeah
everyone thinks something like so what
if they compromise and they say they'll
make it look less like hitler but still
a little bit like hitler somebody made
this picture
like we don't want it to obviously not
the doll look like hitler you know
you have the daily mail picture i mean
it's a picture of hitler that looks like
howling
wait wait somebody made a picture
you can't see it unless you get up and
you can get up and look at it yeah come
on
come on just take that just be careful
with your headphones so somebody
created this image
that's a simpson hitler this guy this
guy john evans it's
john three vans on twitter had no
excuses here
this is amazing yeah that's a bit much
they're crossing a line yeah
smiling it could have been charlie
chaplin
there you go why didn't amazon say it
was char it was it was i thought it was
weird that they changed google's
address to google.ss yeah
[Laughter]
this is uh this is this is the world we
get to inhabit
i'm so excited who complained about this
like
who cared about it's a it's it's the
same people that
do you think it was stocks to the moon
do you think it was like a pro hitler
person that was like this looks too much
like hitler and i don't need
amazon besmirching the great ones
situations
i would never have thought it
hitler would not be allowing you to use
his image to sell stuff to a certain
group of people
but so so what was it you said that if
you if you hear the dog dog whistle
you're a dog
yeah dog so so you hear dog whistles all
the time i'd imagine
i mean we're all sort of trained to hear
all the things right now so it's like
yes if you start i think whatever you
pay attention to of course
but as soon as you get into that game
where it's like right i'm gonna
look for everything bad it's like it's
like doesn't mean you're bad but it
doesn't mean you're looking for it right
it's like saying that's what she said
once you start you can never stop so
once you start like looking for a white
supremacy that is correct yeah you can
never stop and i think that's kind of
what's happened to these people i think
they're kind of losing it did you guys
see
roon gate yes negative so this is
another good example of just like how
stupid and insane everybody is
so the cpac stage is what is it the
conservative political action conference
yeah
they said looks like the nazi
was it called an o'doll rune or
something yeah yeah it's like a nordic
rune
have you seen this it's like a diamond
and then it goes like out and there's
like little wings i guess i feel like
every three months they go look at this
kind of looks like you know
they've had a few superhero things where
they said oh the thing looks too much
like the
ss stage thing yeah the eagle remember
the imagery people are always kind of
saying the imagery looks like nazi
and the nazis took the swastika from
like a hindu
it's a hindu religious icon the odel
rune is like an ancient
celtic nordic thing yeah the second
worst thing they did
yeah seized the room stealing you know
i'm a comedian so
we'll see how much uh uh youtube allows
you to to get away with all that
yeah we got in trouble before right uh
tim i don't wanna talk about my personal
problems that i've had with the great
corporation
google.com which you called them
google's not me
something tim would do yeah and if the
people at google are listening i
appreciate y'all i love you guys
so i'm just trying to get rid of those
strikes so
apparently cpac is getting canceled what
like like i mean i mean cpac was already
pretty canceled dude did you see that
spangled banner no hold on hold on we
got to talk about i don't mean that
they're like shut down i mean
can you see culture cancelled like
they're getting attacked apparently the
hotel
wrote wrote a strongly worded letter
saying like we can't believe that they
used this for
cpac's like christmas to these people it
really is yeah
welcome back everybody i think we just
got booted and
returned back yeah um okay the stages
some people might not even
even notice because it may have just
like stuttered and then hurt you say
welcome back yeah we had a little blink
on the internet you can hear that chime
yeah it's when it but we have redundancy
set up because you know
they try to keep us down it's two days
in a row are we back right now yeah we
are back thank you
we're recording the whole time guess
who's back okay okay unnecessary
the cpac stage is a convenient shape for
a stage
i will say i don't agree with those bad
things you said about google when the
cameras were down
[Laughter]
i don't know whether to complain about
the the corporate response to
these accusations or to complain about
the girl's performance of
the star-spangled banner no oh my god it
was
so many different keys she just kept
changing keys
and there's a video of a guy trying to
play piano along with it
look at simon over here simon simon
cowell dude you gotta watch
judging this woman's singing it's so bad
yeah so funny totally didn't vote for
her
oh my god no i gave her the ex i gave
her the roon
[Laughter]
to do that i mean this girl's career
wasn't like
skyrocketing if she's doing the cpac
anthem i feel like
listen listen conservatives are not cool
nope that's that's always been a big
problem but but i say but to all the
conservatives who are watching
i i realized something with like all of
this cancel culture stuff and like going
back to some of the earlier stuff we
were talking about
ryan have you ever watched like what
what is that god flicks called
pure flicks pure flicks yeah you ever
watch like those old christian versions
of movies and like conservative versions
of like tv shows and stuff
yeah it's like really low quality and
just like really poorly acted
yeah it's in it's inverting now we're
getting
like conservatives are starting to make
content and it's getting better okay i
watched
bill o'reilly interview the insane clown
posse
when was that ten years ago so cool and
he was saying the
exact same thing that these people were
saying he goes
you know you're this is harmful words to
kids
you know it's everything that they were
saying this shouldn't be available we
need
all of the stuff and it was 100 flipped
and you know the insane cl
and they were like you know you're
teaching your kids to you know do all
these bad things and the insane clown
posse who you said you're a big juggalo
fan
but they were kind of like no these
people aren't as stupid as you like
that's it you're just looking for the
worst thing just the same way when they
go
oh look at uh some right-wing guy and
they go look at this thing you said and
you go
you're just trying to find something
like that's not really what they're
about
i was trying really hard to remember the
lyrics to halls of illusion because i
was going to sing
i honestly couldn't remember it but you
know after the world i could say that
oh my gosh he's a bigger no you know
halls of illusion i thought was actually
a good song when i was a kid
dude when i was like in grade six a
little skateboard kid when they came out
and they go in this one song i say f 93
times so i was like
here's a point i make right i'm
imagining like
uh uh i used to there was a channel in
chicago that was like the christian
channel
and they had a bunch of cartoons that
were very hokey and like just
not good storytelling but it was the
religious message
yeah it was like the religion behind it
made it good no matter what
i think about like the static shock
thing where they're making him get his
powers at black lives matter and it's
like watching
when i was a kid watching these
christian cartoons with like you know
like
christian man and it's like he got his
powers from reading the bible and
and praying properly and i'm like you
know what's you know what's
substantially cooler than that version
of static shock
yes so much cooler it's it's
tongue-in-cheek it's like
it's like self-deprecating almost where
they're kind of mocking the idea
so there just isn't as many lines like
you can like listen no one likes to
watch things when they know it's like
really being colored in the lines and
there's just
there's no transgression on it and that
could be like artistic that could be
political whatever it is
so when you completely know exactly what
you're getting and you know why you're
getting it
it's it's less desirable to watch and
you know it doesn't catch cultural heat
and that's why
all of these places are having trouble
like manufacturing the energy to get
people to like their things
well i also think that it's like it's
it's what you were saying earlier you're
allowed to give me one teaspoon of
propaganda for every like cup of
entertainment or whatever yeah
but what happened what happens is you
the the problem with with giving more
propaganda is
that the feeling i get is i'm watching
something and i want to be entertained
if i'm mostly just getting smacked over
the head with a lesson
well then i'll i would rather watch like
reruns of american gladiators
and listen to uh bill hicks screaming my
ear about how i'm
you know you know an idiot for doing it
but it's more entertaining than
watching like religious content look i'm
not trying to rag on religious people
but i tell you when i was growing up and
i saw these like
i went to catholic school and they would
play these cartoons where it was just
like
you know just not good storytelling
but it was the ideology behind it well
so it comes back the idea where you go
okay what would it take for you you know
if someone has a belief like let's say
they're a huge fan of a sports team and
you go
what would it take for you to change
sides like to not be a yankees guy if
they lost like if they didn't make the
playoffs 50 times whatever it was
and they go nothing i'm to the death and
you go okay so i don't really need your
take on them then do i
yeah and i think that's what all this
stuff is if you go you're so in it it's
you know to the death and i'm ride or
die with this ideology
what if what if we're completely wrong
about the static shock thing
and it turns out that the villains were
all black lives matter supporters and
the villains are anti-fun we're just
like we're totally wrong
i mean i gotta see the movie to yeah
comment comment to what it's a comic
i think they should run with that idea
that's the best that i can think of i
mean just sprinkle some danger
i gotta tell you it's probably going to
be the bullies were at a pro-trump
counter rally
and cops will be bad just sounds
terrible but why would the cops
why would the cops tear gas the trump
guys in the same comic like the comics
trying to make the cops bad guys
the cops have to protect the trump
supporters how did the bullies get super
powers
were you reading this have you read the
comic yet just the just the ones they
showed would you hate read it
no i would i would i would legit just
read it that is the one thing of all of
the
you know you could make fun of this
group or that group and people get mad
at you
i did a comic sketch recently where i
had uh
three different comics it was that's
their culture i don't know if you saw it
the superheroes won yeah youtube.com
comedy but then no but i i got probably
the
most people mad ever that i included
different uh heroes from different
universes
of course gamers are the the number one
lobby right now because you had captain
america on the flash and then i had them
all fly and they're like
do i know the actual truth and this is
what happened was sometimes it ain't
like is it wasn't even me being stupid i
go i looked at amazon to buy costumes
and i was like those are the three that
kind of look the best
you put captain america and the green
lantern together
and they all fly no one cares about you
offending
minorities or whatever i don't know
people were fired up about that
cancel ryan long there's okay okay well
hold on hold on let's think about
cancel fire ryan long was the flash the
flash
could spin his arms really really fast
to create
wind pressure yeah theoretically where
were you in my comments section
green lantern can just legit fly so
you're good there and captain america
well
he uh tony stark gave him a um
a repulsor for his yeah
there we go and it allows him to fly
yeah
i think so tim's got you back there you
got the hook now now it it is
uh it is canon but it is i mean so much
of this stuff
because even like i see how fired up you
are about this story like it all kind of
goes back to the game
how many people say that gamergate is
kind of the uh you know the pinnacle of
the whole thing but
it's like the one thing that they're
like we can't have this one
thing like they're it's like okay fine
all your commercials are this okay all
the movies are this
and they're like we want to take your
comics and make them this too and
everyone's like you've gone too far
well it started with it started with
games and there was a meme
of a guy in a military suit with like a
feminist tied up and he says why did you
make me do this i just wanted to play
video games
like the point they were making rather
extreme
is like if you just leave our video
games alone
we didn't care what you were doing
politically dude of course
but then they were like you had you know
you know what it was yeah i just want to
play video games now campaigning for
channels
that's the meme i just wanted to play
video games but so the issue is
i think a lot of this started because
when the blog era began
there was this pressure among these like
low talent midwit
writers to produce content every single
day
if you write for a video game website
and it was the way to get publicity too
well right so check it out you come out
with a
comedy special and i write for a comedy
website
i can only write about your special one
time so what they do is
when when a video game comes out the
video game you know bloggers would write
about the game
write about its release write tips and
tricks and then say now what
what are we right about no games are
getting released we can't just have the
website be dead
i can oh there was uh a guy in the game
and he was he said um yeah
he said big in reference to a woman ooh
that's fat phobic
definitely the content the necessity for
pounds and pounds of content
you know contributed to that's exactly i
mean decided the blog generator where
they just go
there's a uh transphobia problem in
halloween yeah yeah whatever it is he
throws a dildo at the wall
yeah and it sticks to uh it was no that
was the old vice thing
yeah that's old vice mine's right right
mine's the new blogs
all together it's so good yeah sticking
the things on the wall
and it's ryan long comedy yeah so so
basically
exactly you have a formula what was the
formula so there's uh blank
has a blank problem and then i if you
want to get if you want to snazz it up
anything yeah if you want to snazz it up
you can but i included all the articles
that actually exist and then some guy
made the generator
wow and put it online and it was pretty
funny so basically you can pick any word
like i need social justice you do it
yeah yeah and they they really do it and
they'll find anyone and
you go reverse right like there's a
racism problem in the gay community
there's a gay problem in the
black community and they just do the
whole thing over and over and over again
so
but it's so it's a big part of that like
with the content thing but then i think
also
there's this idea that it starts with
the
it starts with the thing but it becomes
about
making you agree to something so that's
kind of like you know let's say the
trans thing right
so it's always became they go a lot of
people
you know why did five comedians all have
their specials about trans stuff right
and they go
why do you guys care so much about this
and i was kind of having this argument
about something that i could have
talking about anything so i was talking
about
fallout boy the band and this girl goes
so fall out boy's a boy band and i go
they're not really a boy band like
they're just kind of a band like i don't
like them without a boy
yeah and i was like a boy band i think
like backstreet boy you know whatever
having this argument before i know it
i'm like
dude they're not you know i'm getting
all fired up and then it becomes like yo
why do you care about followed boys so
much i go i don't care about fall out
boy you're making me say something that
isn't true
and that's kind of a lot of this stuff
gets there and you get fired up and then
they go what do you care about this
thing i don't care about this thing
well that's the thing like so i i
tweeted about potato head
because ap said like mr potato head is
now regular potato head and then
everyone was like it's gender neutral
and i just tweeted how is this is stupid
like how is he even gendered anyway
because his name is mister like that's
so dumb
i don't even care about the story but
then some some article took my tweet to
claim that i was an outraged
conservative
oh angry and i'm like i didn't care
about this you know what so i decided
you know i'm gonna do from now on
i'm just going to tweet the opposite and
so i just tweeted i demand a gender
neutral datehead
and then when when hasbro tweeted out so
do you see the tweet then you go further
you see the tweet from mark dice where
he responded to it saying it's time for
republican states to secede
so in response to the potato head story
he tweeted and then all the leftists
were like they've gone crazy slightly
hyperbole so
when hasbro announced that they didn't
actually get rid of mr
deadhead i tweeted it's time for
democrat states to secede
so it's like call me right wing then
yeah whatever
so now i just decided yeah you're
messing with them i'm just you know
uh michael malus tweeted because we had
ethan sipley on the show
and then he he tricked lydia into
bringing him oh my gosh
to what he texted lydia and he was like
talk about me
yeah he did it worked i said i learned
it i learned from the best
michael i learned from from him how to
tweet properly
because his tweets are always you can't
tell
they're very opaque yeah you don't know
what he's saying yeah he's sort of
in a lot of times is wrapping logic into
weird places too right
and like the the easiest example to
explain to people is when trump would
tweet something he would say we don't
deserve him
so you don't know if he's for or against
trump i think neutral comedy is the best
and uh what was that guy's name um betty
murphy
eddie murphy no no the the dude um
kaufman
andy kaufman love his comedy i mean
people didn't know if it was real or
fake
and i think that's the most because so
many sad to say stupid
people that are bathing in stupidity
think it's real which is funny to me but
it's
also i think can be dangerous it it is
yeah it depends on the time and place i
was just the kaufman thing makes me
laugh because i watched the comedy store
documentary
and it's so funny like to go back and
how much things are romanticized like
even comics like that they're oh this
guy was such a killer but what you don't
remember is how much they bombed at the
time
when i was watching the jim carrey on
the comedy star documentary and they go
he goes before every you know when he
did a bad gig he would go sit in the
piano
and then turn to close the piano and he
goes i won't come out of the piano until
the
the you know until i've had my
punishment and the show's over then he
would get out of the piano and i go
if any of my friends did that i would be
like i am done with this loser
like can you imagine how annoying that
would be if ian had a bad show and he
goes i need to punish myself by
sitting in the thing and i'm going to be
in the fridge all night and you'd be
like all right we need to deal with this
guy and he's like but then in the
history books they write it as like
he's a a you know creative great yeah
yeah yeah he was so in his head but at
the time you'd just be like the biggest
eye roll in history
anyone doing that nothing but that's
what i mean a coffin is great but i bet
you a lot of the things people were
probably just like can you not
i mean look saturday saturday night live
in general is definitely romanticized
yeah i always hear about like people
saying like remember when saturday live
was good and i'm like no
they just remember their era everyone's
like the era that they kind of you know
connected with for a second you know
like for me i remember
sandler and spade and those guys and
yeah if i look back i go i don't know
maybe they people before i thought it
would happen
admit it bro lunch later land is not
funny wayne's world was good lunch
punch ladies are my favorite movies was
not funny lunch ladyland yeah like chris
farley adam sandler sandler is playing
the guitar and then everyone's there and
yeah
tracy morgan's just standing there i
think right one of his originals nor
mcdonald's in it that whole thing so
yeah yeah
i don't know but i think you have to you
i mean maybe you were looking at the
context at the time but i think a lot
of those things looking at them after
you don't realize
that the point of it was how stupid it
was you know in the context of like what
the comedy at the time was so
you know i think i it feels kind of like
how tick-tock's all like random nonsense
right now like how willing are you
to listen to this because it's funny to
me that you're actually paying money to
listen to me
snowball you with things i know aren't
funny like that's the comedy of andy
kaufman in my
opinion i feel like snl is actually
starting to get a little bit more
courageous
i don't really watch it all that much
but they have done some bits where i'm
like i'm really surprised they don't
want cuomo
i'm pretty sure they had cuomo and they
had um
who else was in it do you remember i
don't remember it was they were making
fun of
oh yeah it was called no cuomo it was it
was an end what happens is it's him and
another guy but someone else made that
joke
no no it was uh they did a bit about ted
no they didn't
i am the first okay what did they say so
the ted cruz bit was like him being
really weasely
and just agreeing with whatever they
told him to say and then he was wearing
like
cancun clothes or whatever okay a bunch
of conservatives got mad and they were
like
what are they gonna rag on cuomo and
then some like liberals were like
that's the same sketch and and then they
put out the full clip and then you see
cuomo's there getting ragged for
murdering
you know yeah so i was like oh wow
but but you know what like democrats
really hate cuomo now for whatever
reason
it's like they got their their their
orders i guess they 100
sending him to the you know he's he's
out there there's protesters right now i
guess outside like
yeah office chanting resignation or
whatever god he's done
i mean it was but let's be real it's
because snl was brave enough to stand up
to him
that these these democrats finally
potentially you might be
it might be happening the other oh yeah
i don't think that would you do snl ryan
if they offered it to you
um i've had conversations about doing
that lots of that stuff but i'm
fairly not interested in general to take
i mean i i was in like traditional media
my whole career in canada and when i
came here it's like i was pretty
into doing the other things so the the
same way that i'm saying these
corporations and all that stuff like
there's such a cost of that like right
now
who's all the best people they're all
kind of doing their own thing like we're
i think i'm making good things right now
and those
like systems the money isn't a lot of
times
so much greater for all the nonsense you
have to deal with all the
slowing you down and i think that maybe
in 10 years i'd be you know let's do one
of those but i think right now
it's just that would be like just
ultimate like handcuffs
i also i also feel like the comedy you
put up on social media
is standing on the line
of where you're poke you're like you're
legit poking the censorship bear
whereas snl would be like pull it back
pull it back but i'm yeah 100
but and it's not like i don't have any
lines like when i'm making my things i
have my own perspective
and you know i think try to be where
it's funny i don't just try to
you know just be like like sarah
silverman where she just says offensive
things
that was like a style that was the hot
thing back then yeah but my point is i'm
more concerned with
and i think that a lot of people and
even more so younger people to me it's
like
the same what you're doing i want to
make i want to make my own snl like i
want to
like i've i've my i ran my other tv
shows like i want to be snl's competitor
i don't want to
join someone else's army machine that's
been there for a hundred years and they
have all these things they're beholden
to yeah you don't need saturday night
anymore i mean the
the venues change it's now internet and
it's it's static you know it can be any
time any day it can
be ever present this whole like let's
all sit around it's set on saturday
the monday night shows it's all done
it's like done it's packed yeah but i
want to be lauren michaels not
you know the new guy on snl right now
well yeah let's do it
freak that's what i'm saying i've got a
ton of offers from a ton of companies
and it's like i wonder if people who
like watch or listen to this show ever
wonder why it is that
timcast.com has its own website and not
a part of any any one of these other
political podcasting networks
it's because i'm you know i'll be honest
i'm just smarter than all of them and
they haven't made an offer yet no
and and once they finally come and just
give me anything guys please i'll just
sign right away no it's i've had a lot
of conversation with some of these big
networks and
i got i got to tell you i'm a bit of i
would i would i would swear right now
but
yeah i'm uh an arrogant prick like i've
i've been
straight up like i had an e i had i was
in i was
approached by one of the biggest podcast
companies ever
like in existence right now on the left
fourth mic
tim poole yeah that's right no no i'm
not talking about a podcast i'm talking
about a network that produces them and
then distributes them
and they they were basically like we
want to sign you it's going to be great
here's how much money you're going to
make you're going to you're going to
rival ben shapiro it's going to be the
biggest show ever and i was like
wow looks like look at all this and your
hat have to get a little smaller
they told me i had to take the hat off
and i was like get out of here
no no but uh i told him straight up
so the general idea is there's a lot of
there's a lot of interest in a moderate
like left-leaning podcast because you
have a lot of leftist podcasts
you have a lot of you know offensive
humor podcasts and you have tons of
conservative talk radio
and so they're like we like the space
you're occupying because you know it's
it's there's definitely a market there
and i said straight up if you get me a
contract
that is legitimate and fair and doesn't
waste my time
i'll sign it but you know what they do
in the entertainment industry because
you probably deal with this
they send you the stock garbage contract
that basically says you work for us you
sign this over
and i responded one time with i will
give you one more chance to send me a
real contract offer
and their response was and he put the
slap emojis in between the words
send me the real content
they they say what i hear often is look
it's standard business
just send it to your lawyer and i said
have a nice day you didn't want to get
the lawyers involved
the issue is if if you expect me to do
business with you
under the pretense that i have to spend
thousands of dollars on a lawyer to fix
your garbage contract
you're wasting my time and money so i
don't feel comfortable doing business
with you and you're making millions of
dollars
being an independent contract basically
working for yourself why would you ever
ever give that i understand rogan i
guess i mean 100 million is a lot of
money
but i would never give up your creative
freedom
you know it's like he might have done
you know whatever everyone has their own
reasons but like
right now where the energy is in making
things and where the energy is
in entertainment and especially comedy
is not
in the like mainstream platforms right
now that are you know have
a bucket of problems there it's which is
kind of a
it's a fun way to look at it is ev every
one of us
you know entertainment when i was in
music all same thing you kind of were
like oh you don't want to sell out right
there's this idea that like you want to
kind of stay true
and they're making it real real easy to
not sell out right because you go these
places suck
they don't even really want you to begin
with so it's like they're you know
reluctantly
giving you contracts just because you're
popular so it's like they're making it
pretty easy to be like yo
you know they they they promise you
everything and give you nothing yeah and
that's that's usually what it is
and so it's like and then now they're
looking you make so much money they go
these people
that's the only way to do it is to give
them rogan style where like they drop a
big bag at your cask
big bag of cashiers because they're so
late to the mark yeah look at these
young guys the milk boys logan paul
these guys it's like if you want to get
them to do anything it's like
these guys have so much money it's too
late so what are you offering them
exactly tying their hands behind their
back no the thing that you think they
think they're offering you is like
legacy
uh you know like yeah but you get to go
to the
yeah you get to the shift manager at a
blockbuster 2003.
things are going pretty good they're
essentially you know they're offering
you the middle management position in
hollywood that's a
but you get to be pretty freaking famous
you'll meet brad pitt
more likely you know all that kind of
stuff so it's the legacy nonsense they
want to give you the watch right i also
think that
i i think like our generation cares a
lot less about that idea yeah
there's a lot of people who want that
prestige but i'm like i don't
look i i think brad pitt was amazing at
fight club i think he's in a bunch of
great movies
i think he's got dumb politics if i met
him i'd say oh cool dude like
fight club is an amazing amazing movie
and
uh world war z was cool and uh you know
i think the ocean's movies were fun
nice to meet you they're grandfathered
in legacy you're not going to be
grandfathered in you know what i mean
like there's a lot of people that really
thirst for that legacy attention
it comes from insecurity it comes from
you know being new to the game and it
also comes from like
uh people that have a need for like a
dad
you know a lot of people need a manager
and they need parents to sort of you
know give them approval tell them what
to do a lot of people can't be their own
like
what do you mean i'm going to be that
like so i think that you know it comes
from that too a lot of people need it
i'll tell you this i've gotten calls
from some of the big very obvious
networks about signing and i just said
i'll be honest i'm starting a company
that's going to be your competition yeah
and they're like okay
and i'm like so i don't want to sign
under you i'll get back to you in five
years when i'm making you the same offer
and i'm buying your company out
oh smackdown he said that to the local
arby's chain
dude i i have good food let me tell you
a story let me tell you a story so um
yeah i worked for advice how about you
work for
my uh hot dog you think i'm joking no
you said that device
let me tell you a story so i once heard
a story about i was reading about vice
i worked at vice i i got flown out to
antalya turkey to party with the
executives and
and the higher ups and uh hung out with
shane sometimes like a couple times not
like i was good friends with everything
but shane dawson youtube yeah that's
right a few things not changed
but uh i wrote a story about how when
they were up and coming he went to this
meeting with like viacom
and he was walking around like looking
at the expensive paintings
and like you know checking out the the
furniture and everything as if he was
expecting to have it
and own it and buy it and his attitude
was very much
i'm smarter i'm better i'm faster and
i'm going to buy you and then where did
the guy end up
look you can you can complain all day
and all day and night about vice but for
a while they were the
the cream of the crop in terms of
digital media and they were worth an
obscene amount of money
and then the dude cashed out or he is at
least well he cashed out he's
he's rich forever and and so i heard
these stories and i've
just straight up been like that's that's
that's the attitude you're sure of
yourself
you don't got to be a dick but you go
into these meetings and you're like
i know what i'm doing and i'm so
confident what i'm doing
i don't want your money i don't need
your money in five years i'll be
i will own your company the first part
of it's the hugest part you know
you know what you want to accomplish and
that's not always you can put in words
sometimes it's energy
you know you kind of know where you want
to go like what you want
mark you want to leave like what you
want to create what what you what energy
you want to kind of leave on this world
and
and you look at these places and they
offer you things you go i don't think
this helps really you know and sometimes
it might right and you might align but
right now if they're doing their best to
make themselves unattractive
to the top talent yep come here
you'll make a good amount of money but
you'll have no long-term prospects
because we'll own the ip
and if you do anything you can we can
make you disappear you know but there's
also
you know with the canceling stuff with
with
everything that's happening in the world
you go
if i was coming out of university like
college right now or high school
the the obvious answer is you got to
like start your own thing that you're
going to own even if it's a small comp
but whatever you do
it should be your own thing because
these jobs are too disposable the
world changes too much you have to kind
of create your own let's let's talk
about bill burr
in this context so we have this story
from cbr
the mandalorian bill bird defends gina
carano slams cancel culture
comedian actor and podcaster bill burke
calls out the toxic nature of cancel
culture and defends his fired
mandalorian co-star gina carano
well good for him absolutely but this
story
about gina chrono exactly exemplifies
what you were just saying about
why take the risk you sound like 20 you
sign with one of these companies they
could just snap their fingers and fire
you because you said
a word someone didn't like at some point
maybe in six months maybe a year
take it away as quick as they gave it to
you yeah and and the problem is
let's say you sign a deal that says like
maybe maybe they're buying you out
or maybe they're like okay we're gonna
buy your
show we'll own it and we'll pay you this
large amount of money and it's like
here's the money up front for the show
and then you'll get x amount of dollars
to continue producing the show as lead
producer executive
and then they also have a morality
clause where it says if you do
anything obscene they could terminate
you you're like i got this really great
deal it's awesome
let's be real joe rogan i'd have to
imagine that spotify has some control in
that regard
yeah where they could you know be like
oh look what you said and you know we
talked i don't wanna
necessarily you know talk about joe's
deal because who the hell knows but i
think that it
all of this stuff it's they want to take
this as just a given
you know that old thing where it's like
these people think they can just move
chess pieces around
and you know people don't react to what
happens
but the truth is like i know people with
normal jobs and they go there and they
make them sign the clauses about what
they put on twitter and what they put on
facebook and you go
this is people are starting to realize
this when they get this
now the same way that if someone gives
you a job and you go oh it's 50 miles
away from my house that's going to be a
bit of a pain
the same way you're getting a contract
that says oh you know you can't be on
twitter you can do this
so all it takes is for other companies
to realize like there's monetary values
on
all of these things if i go yeah okay i
get 60 grand here for whatever you know
my
middle job or whatever but i'm allowed
to say whatever i want or this place is
offering
you know 7 65 grand but they kind of is
this five grand worth me not but that
but a lot of people don't i think people
are starting to
factor these things intrinsically the
you know the level of what these places
are asking for you they want you to act
like you're the president to work at a
freaking
bank well let me let me read a little
bit from bill burr to show you what he
said uh for those unfamiliar gina carano
she was one of the stars on the
mandalorian disney plus show it's a star
wars show
and she posted on instagram the the
photo she used was of actual nazi
germany probably not a good photo to use
but the context was don't demonize your
neighbors
over their political views she didn't
compare anybody to republicans
she actually just posted the amazon logo
yeah it was just the amazon logo
but but uh here's what bill burr said
they said on the bill burt podcast he
said she was an absolute sweetheart
super effing
uh super nice effing person unless she
did some truly horrible ish or said
something over some overtly racist ish
he continued
i don't know i think there is just too
many channels and then you gotta do
sensational ish
i don't know what the f it is i'm on
that effing show now i gotta watch what
the f i say
i think that was that was that was
actually great on billboard's part yeah
but
that represents the every man but that's
the point they could cancel him for this
they could cancel him for this
he's probably got a morality clause in
his contract that says if you say
something offensive
but who defines offensive so he comes to
the fence
of gina chrono saying she was super
effing nice oh give me two seconds for
some woke left us to get angry
and then disney's gonna be like bill you
can't come out and defend this stuff
they're probably not gonna do it but
they could if they want to who in their
right mind would sign a dumb contract
like that well this is for
for him specifically he does indeed
these things and
he's in the position of power a little
bit where if they go
oh we kick him off this show we go oh
whatever okay whatever it's the tenth
thing i do you know what i mean so
there there's like a power dynamic when
it stops being something you need
and something that you could do or not
do but there there is a bigger issue
there
the cascade effect if he gets cancelled
from the show
and then disney issues a statement
saying he he defended racist comments
and was extremely offensive and we had
no choice
then other companies might be like look
there's a backlash going on we don't
want to absorb any of that
you know not to just be like the
complete like free market or sorted out
guy
but yeah and if that happens the next
generation of people like me and my
friends
are gonna be like no don't take a job on
those places dude do you remember what
happened to bill burr that's exactly
what's happening right now exactly
exactly what we're saying
yes i won't this is why i don't sign any
of these contracts
i know that if i sign any of these deals
with any one of these networks it'll
it's a matter of time i don't even trust
you live like that
i don't even trust these conservative
networks that i don't i don't think they
would have your back if you said
something
well also even if they will right now in
this context of like the culture war
dynamic
what does that look like in a year and a
half i don't know man things change
pretty quickly
yeah i mean maybe i i i would i would
i would argue many of the conservative
channels have much more integrity than
many of the
traditional hollywood type stuff i just
wouldn't sign those deals
ideally in my you know what i've kind of
said i like the idea of a
on like a non-partisan network to begin
with like
even when like think about music it's
kind of like what you want
is uh like a guy that's like hey i don't
really get it but the kids seem to not a
not a guy that like has a lot to say to
you what you want is a network that's
like
yeah people seem to responding to this
it's funny or you know tim seems to have
a big audience people like it we should
get him on
a person who's going to be like oh so we
host this one guy the left hates him
he's really offensive we don't know a
whole lot about you know
we don't care too much it makes money
for us we do have this lefty guy in our
network though and he does these things
the conservatives really hate them
when you want somebody who approaches
like a business that's what i that's
what i think that a lot of people like
especially the younger people are kind
of looking at it like that
i don't care what your political values
are which is but the bigger issue is
when they're scared and it's a business
they say we don't want to lose half our
customers because they're freaking out
so bye-bye yeah
with gina carano i didn't know who she
was before the scandal
and bill burr is a superstar so like
they they look at their bottom line
they're like you know we can afford to
lose gina we can't afford to lose bill
it's mine well bilberry is a comedy
superstar he's not like an a-list
hollywood actor in that context i mean
you know i don't know exactly what the
hierarchy looks like but it's
the little world i live in some of these
people we go oh god that's
the biggest guy in the world and then he
swears a lot yeah but matt damon walks
in and everyone goes oh
freaking matt you realize the difference
isn't the weirdest thing it's just like
why who cares obviously who cares but
that's just
the way the world is it's a really
interesting subject because um i don't
think we talked with ethan sipley
about this specifically on the show but
we did briefly touch on it i i wanted to
get into this more
but this idea that the traditional idea
of fame is over
because now you have hbo max i think
it's called hbo max
where they're doing simultaneous theater
releases and streaming releases
so people aren't going to go to the
movie theaters for these big movies and
spend
20 bucks per person anymore for the most
part they're gonna spend 20 bucks for
the whole movie and then watch it with
like 50 people at their house while they
order pizza or whatever
so why would someone cast tom cruise
brad pitt
you know who who was the person you
mentioned damon matt damon one of them
one of those one of those
two brothers you you booked them because
you put their name on top of the movie
right yeah yeah and that way people see
it in the marquee and they see it in the
ads and they say oh i want to go see
this and they go to the theaters
i think now that there's so many
different streaming services
so many different movies coming out like
i mentioned that one movie spiral came
out on shutter it just came out
i watched it it's not a blockbuster
movie but
all the movies are basically being made
equal at this point sure there'll be big
marketing and big budget campaigns
how did that work out for a wonder woman
apparently wonder woman like fizzled and
made barely any money
because it was a streaming release yeah
and that's with me renting it 50 times
yeah i know and i you know i i i signed
up for 50 accounts to buy it because i
just love gal gadot no no but seriously
why pay gal gadot you know 20 million
dollars to do a movie
when you don't need her name on it
because it's not going to do that well
anyway
yeah especially when they've lost like
hollywood
mastered their star-making formula you
know the way that certain labels have in
the past or whatever like they were able
to
make her and then you know sign her to
these contracts and it was all part of
the system
so they bring people in and they make
them you know the next gal gadot
whatever it is right
but they're doing everything in their
power to like ruin their vouch
and their star system so with when i go
back to
the younger kids and i think me and you
are around this image we're in the
middle
there's a lot of young people right now
that they've mastered they they have
these huge instagram accounts
youtube channels tick tock they know how
to make another guy so that like
you know i could talk about the nilk
boys you know i just think those guys
are interesting but they
they literally brought another guy in
brought him got him to a million
followers
got his channel to a million followers
then they're like we should start a
management company
they basically mastered star making the
same way that hollywood has
so just called just at the same time
hollywood's wrecking their star making
because they go check out this comic
they're so funny and everyone's like huh
they go what about this one they go huh
and then everyone's like we got to stop
paying attention so these guys are
wrecking their star making things think
about it same time everyone else is
figuring it out hollywood
is like blockbuster video they've
basically become
the old stodgy uncool
you know or they're becoming old stodgy
and uncool like you mentioned like kids
know how to
know how to be make stars themselves
they know how to use social media they
don't need the system anymore
but it's also the worlds are completely
separate
like the ad revenue system on
traditional media is so different from
digital media it's changing though
it's getting close like a lot of these a
lot of these places i mean
youtube is worth more than instagram and
you know it's all based on how people
buy but
it's not it's not that crazy different
well but but it kind of is check this
out
when you buy an ad on say tucker
carlson's show
you're not gonna get like the numbers
you get for tucker's ratings are an
estimate based on a sample size from
like nielsen big boxes that no one's
actually using
i mean so you're hoping it's true yeah
um and it's probably close
with digital we know the exact number
so what happens you know the exact
demographic of that number
well so with with the internet you can
refine your ads and really maximize your
price point and your and your profit
with buying ads on tv they basically
tell you here's how much it costs for an
ad
it's like you know that some websites
say it's like rachel matt's like
8 500 for a commercial to run on her you
know on her channel
these advertisers will think very much
money yeah you start a big business
go try to buy a commercial on logan
paul's podcast i'm sure right more than
that
absolutely way more than that i
guarantee you it's going to cost way
more than that
so you and she's getting she gets what
like two to three million
and premium ads he's got nike i was
watching uh when you watch fox news i
told you this earlier but it made me
laugh so much that
they can't get good sponsors so they
have sleep apnea mask cleaner that's
[ __ ] just
they have the funniest ads like
orthotics uh you know remover
so i'll write this point up and then
we'll get into that a little bit
uh basically these advertisers spend the
eight grand
and then just look at their sales and
see if they go up
and then try and figure out if the ad
campaign worked with
online i can literally see people click
the link
yeah i know if the link is actually
working yeah so
what's happening is in a lot of ways
there's more ad space there's more real
estate for ads so the prices go down
but anyway at the rest the main point of
this is it's a totally different world
based on a lot of guessing and now it's
it's going away
it's becoming worth less and less and
less fox news is running pillow
commercials and sleep apnea commercials
rachel maddow's ads are are like i gotta
tell you man
and they're not even the parts that they
can and to go back to
because you're so right but the even
worse part of it is
that even the data they do have they
don't want to listen to
for other reasons it's the equivalent of
they go actually
this per this is what they like there's
a huge market for this perspective the
world's craving
you know this perspective and then they
go what if we go with this one and you
go
this numbers are way higher on this one
yeah we can't do that check this out
i'll give everybody some some top secret
information oh
so you can you can google search this
uh if you look up like cable channel ad
rates they say
i i just said rachel maddow because i
was looking into it it's like 8 500
i think for a 30 second 30 seconds do
you know how much it would cost you
for 30 seconds on
okay so so she gets like 3 million
viewers if you found a youtube video
with three million views do you know
what you would cost you to get a promo
spot in that youtube video
yeah three million sixty grand yeah
that's about right about sixty thousand
dollars if somebody can get
three million views per video they're
probably selling it for like 50 to like
75 depending on where the ad appears
and whether or not they consider
themselves to be a premium brand that is
better
and you don't have to film an ad you
just go hey also instead of filming a
billion dollar commercial you go hey go
check out you know tim's beanies
yup so companies will say here's the
script promote it here's what we want to
see
and then the youtubers do all the work
like when we do the ads we i just read
and talk about the product
and so it actually costs less because
you don't have to make it i would say
that it costs more money probably
well it's hard to say depending on the
segment we do it can cost more money to
advertise on this podcast than it would
on rachel meadow
yeah easily that's crazy the old world
is in decay
yeah you know so so anyway the main
point of this segment because it's like
we've we've veered to a bunch of
different stuff
i would never sign a contract with any
of these big networks if fox news
or cnn or any well if cnn and msnbc came
to me and they're like would you like to
sign i'd be like
surely you just if fox news came to me i
would also be like are you kidding
no not gonna happen i wouldn't sign with
any of these companies now for the
digital media ones
i think it's great that they're smarter
and doing better in their business
models
but you know what you know what we're
gonna do we're launching a new podcast
soon it's gonna be crime cults mystery
and the paranormal it's gonna be
evergreen stories not news related we've
got some
crazy stuff we're getting lined up it's
it's legit so we've got some like
like potential cult members and people
who
deny ever being a nicole yes yeah so
it's going to be like cool guess it's
going to be like
a bit of scripted but we're going to
start producing this content and we're
going to create a new site that's going
to be
you know non-partisan content so it'll
have talk it'll have con it'll have
jokes it'll have entertainment
and then we're going to create something
bigger and better than all of these
other platforms and it needs to happen i
want to build
like like these multi-channel networks
kind of thing and like start like an
organization but i want to make sure
that the people that we sign
and empower are are fully empowered that
we don't like end up ripping them off
with like
we own your content we own your ad
revenue like i want to give people
an old school bro i know that makes no
sense yeah think about this
there are a lot of companies that say
we're gonna sign you
and you'll start a new youtube channel
and we'll pay you
but we keep the youtube channel and i'm
like why what happens in the contract is
up
are you gonna produce content let's
let's say someone signs you ian and
they're like you'll make a youtube
channel but we own the youtube channel
a year later the channel is dead it's
making like pennies
a month worthless and you don't produce
anymore
what are they going to do are is some
like executive going to be like i'm john
for the ian channel
they tried doing it discovery tried
doing this i think it was now this
was it now this that sounds right they
bought discovery or something
and then or something happened and then
they changed it was like one of the
discovery channels turned into and now
this channel everyone's like we don't
want this we didn't subscribe to this
you can't turn netflix into amazon and
expect everyone to be like okay
so so it's dumb now the way the
traditional media works saying
make a social media channel and we own
it great so in two years you'll have a
dead property that's stupid
let the person keep it as part of the
incentive package i don't want to own it
they're your followers i'm not going to
take your twitter from you
but you know that these big cable
channels do this when you get hired they
make you create a new twitter
they own it's crazy yep it's like the
second potus twitter
the second potus yeah like the the
president has his old twitter and then
he gets his nude
president twitter oh right right right
right yes and then i have to transfer it
over
it makes sense to have in your contract
like you'll make the channel
and for the duration of our contract we
get the revenue from it and we control
it as if we did own it
upon your contract ending then well a
lot of range i guess they change
they keep the show going without you
that's the other thing they reserve well
but i mean like a lot of these deals
that are happening now with youtube are
like
we're gonna sign you to do a new youtube
show that you host because people really
like you and then we keep the channel
and i'm like
okay then keep the dead ip after i leave
it makes no sense
the deal should be yeah but then they
make they go uh tim cast
in irl hosted by dj qualls
dj quality yeah wow what a throwback to
that guy
where did that come from i just thought
it would be a good replacement
i was telling tim dude i'd be stoked to
have him on the show that'd be awesome
i want to do like build a network like
that where where you empower the user
to own their own content and to like see
them flourish but you just kind of
create like a seed organization that's
like an mcn
yeah but like inverted where you don't
you're not in it to rip these guys off
you really want to see them get because
that's how you attract the best i'm sure
if you ask them they're uh wouldn't say
oh yeah we're in this to rip these guys
off but
right they all start like that well i
was involved with maker studios in the
early days
yeah the big ones yeah i watched a lot
of the the contracts go awry like philip
defranco was part of it in the very
beginning and they were on
all his revenue and he was like why am i
realized pretty he was the first one to
realize like why am i
doing all this work and paying all this
revenue to make her when i could just be
keeping it all myself
peace guys so i took that as like i
learned my life i've had a lot of
conversations with these youtube people
and and you're kind of like
i go i don't listen i'm like a loopy guy
but i don't think i'm
stupid and then i like have these
conversations and they sell me the whole
pitch and i go
okay i just listen you talk for like 20
minutes and i like honest to god have no
idea what you're
what you're going for what do you guys
do like what do these companies do
like no and we have take your channel
and there's like tips and tricks and we
have
we maximize this and maximum and you go
what are you talking about what do you
do
i have a i have a big announcement to
make ladies and gentlemen we are we are
here today
with ryan long on the spot i'm going to
make him an offer right now to to join
the new network now here's the deal
we're going to make a new channel and
we're going to call it ryan long comedy
two we
own it we get all the money uh-huh can
you just tell me this is the worst idea
and no
idiot would take this that's the joke
yeah oh yeah
because but they keep it you can't have
it ian started talking but you're
working i will play ryan
making all the money and then jim's like
and i haven't forgotten about this
making all the money
and we're replacing you with ian yes oh
yeah what's the contract
no no we're just straight up doing it
we're buying you and then recasting you
with ian buying the ip yeah i'm in
long comedy it's a win-win
it's number two and it's uh you know
there's like a little poop emoji because
it's like
double on tons all right let's uh let's
go
let's let's let's take some of these
super chats from a lot of people who are
having some some questions and stuff
talking about static shock and all that
if you haven't already go to timcast.com
sign up to become a member because
if you've been listening to this episode
thus far i can only imagine that the
exclusive members-only content is going
to get us in serious trouble because
ryan really really just
is poking the bear as the you're giving
me the funniest intro where you're like
this guy is going to be no holds barred
as soon as we finish you're going to be
like okay do your edgy thing
and he's going to like put on a suit and
tie before uh ryan when 6 million people
died in the holocaust no
no no no no no no no no no no
now we're not being that edgy not that
although apparently you don't need to
watch the exclusive episode now because
he's already saying these things
no let's read super chats before
before ryan gets banned from the
internet awesome all right all right uh
smash that like button
and again tipguys.com don't forget to
subscribe and share and all that good
stuff
americafloat says people watching this
content night after night may also enjoy
america floats channel
and the af's deep and sidecar channel
thank you tim for watching what you say
and keeping your channel afloat
very cool that's the best way to get a
free ad spot on this channel that's not
bad eh
ten bucks yeah better than 60 grand
that's right that's well written i like
that
christine h says have caitlyn bennett on
the show does she get mad that they call
her gun girl
i don't think so they call her the gun
girl joe kosh says please invite agent
smith from china uncensored
are we going to we're having china oh
wait yeah yeah i'm not allowed to say
not a secret anymore yeah
trent lamolino says dude i always push
my friend about wanting a static shock
and
and zoids live-action show movie
it's it's a bummer they're changing
static shock to be some stupid black
lives matter protest thing because the
original story was legit
that's too bad whatever i guess kids you
know
they're probably like some 13 year old
like that stupid old man thinks static
shock is dumb what a loser he's so dumb
yeah but there is also that thing of and
it always goes back there but it's like
can't you just make new things like if
hollywood wasn't so freaking lazy
they're like if you want to make a black
lives matter superhero make a black
lives matter yeah yeah
just like take everything and remake it
differently
like just start from scratch and write a
movie are you not hollywood
all right let's see we got here what's
uh oh someone's talking about ryan
sub-zero beef says ryan long equals pro
breakdancer
lace the loop is that true i went on uh
louis gomez's podcast in new york and we
were having a competition he said that i
couldn't do lace the loop if you know
what that is it's when you hold your one
leg and then jump over the other leg oh
yeah yeah and then uh i did it and fell
over and smashed their tv
[Laughter]
oh there you go i still did it though
physical comedy all right
what broke says tim i never super chat
but i'm begging you to look into getting
jp sears onto the show
youtube channel awaken with jp dude has
arguably some of the boldest political
commentary on youtube
yeah but he's also a really really big
channel the one thing people need to
understand about
uh getting other people who host shows
is that they're like i'd love to come on
your show but i host my own show i don't
have time or why would i you know what i
mean
what the hell is that supposed to mean
he looked at you right when he said it
you know we can't get people that are
like big for example or high quality
no no like how how often do you put out
content uh i mean he is kind of a jp
does a sort of a similar thing to me but
i think he's very funny
and rich it's it's like what i'm trying
to say is
for people i'm not saying this about jp
he does put out a lot of content though
there's like you know people like kyle
kalinski for instance it would be really
hard to book because he does
a daily show when's he going to take
time off his show to come do my show
that makes that's not what jp sears does
no i know i know that's what i'm saying
i wasn't referring to him specifically
about you know that kind of stuff
did you just take my water oh maybe oh
here's mine oh geez you legit
just took my water bottle we're stealing
water from each other oh [ __ ] crap
we're sharing cooties i'm throwing a
beanie
that's how you know but you are right
it's for people that do a daily show it
is very difficult yeah
yeah it's almost impossible all right we
got nyasha miso says keep up the good
work would you be
able to get tom mcdonald on your show um
yes as soon as he's available i suppose
fellow canadian that's right
dude we can't we can't have there's like
50 canadians who have birthdays
and i'm like would you like to come on
the show and they're all like oh that'd
be amazing when and i'm like as soon as
you're available and they're like we're
locked in canada that'd be great and i'm
like oh
they can't come are they ever are they
ever locked in canada yeah yeah
so you got family up there right now
they are in
certain places so if you're in like
ottawa they have a
curfew and they actually give people
tickets for it so there's people
there's all these stories of you know a
woman that she's dropping her kid i mean
they sound like freak cases but there
are lots of them and i know people that
have had this
she's dropping her kids off at her mom's
house and she stayed there and then the
neighbors called the cops because
there's five people there and then they
get a
thousand dollar ticket and people were
just out
it's honestly so comical i'm just like
yeah a country you guys are
out of control over there but you know
i'm sure that some people that live some
places are like
that's fine here and whatever i'm not
even obeying it and blah blah blah but
not their huh they're lacking people in
hotels so if you want to go back
this is the the funniest one and
australia has this too so
australia is even funnier so they
basically lock you in a hotel
and you really can't leave and my buddy
evan demere who's a comic
from canada he was locked in the hotel
because he's in australia right now
and while he was there one of the girls
that was there
was like screw this she's like a party
girl and she tried to escape
and then people filmed her trying to
escape so they got it on video
news covered it cops came they found the
girl brought her back and then they had
a guard outside of the girl's door
yeah she was trying to go to escape to
go party right wow uh no
will they bring her back she was already
in jail they bring her back to her
current jail and
nobody can only come out for a peanut
butter sandwich they charge people with
crimes for that
yeah i'm not sure the extent of what
happened with this girl
um but in canada they started
essentially
being like okay you have to stay at this
hotel and also you have to pay for the
hotel
yeah since yeah that's a couple well
yeah so i'm just not going back
i mean which is fine whatever but all
right we got uh greg
bohan i'm probably planting that wrong
he says you want to talk about dc and
social justice infestation
you should get a hold of ethan van
skiver on comic of comic artist pro
secrets on youtube
his peers run him out of dc comics and
cancelled him
because he was a out republican
interesting
a gay republican apparently
matt m says ryan stokes to see your show
next week in orlando
oh yeah i'm doing orlando and tampa next
uh
next month and again buy tickets because
ryanlongcomedy.com for tickets because
all of the shows have been selling out
and they've been super fun it's been
cool
famous it's been cool dude everyone come
out because
we haven't i've been toured america
since i moved here and then we're like i
think we could there's enough places
open so we started doing it and it's
been
i was like oh man this is way better
with your comedy you're basically
hosting like mini clan rallies is that
what it is oh wow
okay wow minnie tim come on
i'm not offended by the clan rally part
i'm offended by that you think my shows
don't have a lot of people
all right we gotta no that's the funny
part that
even just touring one thing i'll say
that kind of funny is that
anyone that kind of you know that people
get mad at online they think that and
you go to the shows and it's like
people of all races like you know
somebody dudes group of girls it's just
everyone right and the funniest part
that i feel like people get wrong about
everything is whenever you're talking
about like race and stuff
well i mean other people have said this
but going back on the road made me
realize it so much
people can't wait for you to talk about
their group like if i'm doing
there was like a table of like hasidic
jewish dudes when we were at the other
table
and i started doing juice stuff they're
like they're dying they're like to us
and then there was like these indian
dudes and they're kind of like
us yeah like especially people that do
all race stuff like russell peters like
the people go for like if you're doing
japanese the like koreans are like like
they think they love you like nailing
their things did you see the dr seuss
thing that happened they like canceled
dr seuss books yeah i started that
oh yeah i started the hashtag all right
so so one of the things i got canceled
was it said the china man who eats with
stick
eats with sticks or whatever and it's
just a cartoon guy
wearing traditional chinese clothing and
he's running and he's got a bowl of rice
and they they ban the book they they
stopped publishing the book because of
that
and i'm like how is that offensive i
don't understand it's literally just
someone who drew a picture of a chinese
guy you know eating rice
yeah i'm offended i guess [ __ ] was
offensive oh no you're gonna say china
person yeah china person
yeah no okay look i i i don't know
i guess i'm not allowed to be offended
by anything ever because i'm not
completely asian and not completely
white so the left just tells me to shut
up and like get into the corner you're
like that uh
that new tv show that the clip went
viral for which one was that you didn't
see that no
oh oh yeah yeah yes yes yes yes the
netflix show where she's like you're
closer to white than i'll ever
meet god so but i'm i'm not offended at
all by these
these things and but based on what you
were saying
if you if you go to a show and you play
an instrument like you play guitar and
they're making fun of the drummers
you're kind of like
okay do guitars like right they're ready
to do their thing i want to be involved
make fun of me yeah yeah and especially
if you know what you're talking about
like you go something go that's freaking
my mom like people yeah yeah yeah
all right i'm not reading this one
comment but basically a woman says you
get her very excited
to play simply oh actually ticket trying
long comedy
but he saw you're in the cucumber show
says hey tim i emailed tim cass recently
about my animated series
spoofing the apple store called cucumber
coming to kickstarter april 1st
cucumber has risen.com has story info
and the trailer
as does our youtube channel thanks hello
lydia and ian it's cute hello
yeah it's uh the green lantern's porn is
called cucumber
cucumber bo just says that static shock
reboot sounds like bible man level
writing mainstream entertainment has
basically devolved into early 2000's
christian media quality tim was that's
what i'm saying man you've been saying
it's like a religion i mean
yeah just another example listen ladies
and gentlemen
uh should we make sure should i tell
people what's going on with our pillow
maybe oh yeah yeah yeah so i've talked a
bit about it and
the the so ryan is going to be helping
me yeah basically i said i'll take your
project to the top
kid the top kid and then you know
basically what happened was
i was leaving uh i was hanging out in
the stands at a venue
as ryan was leaving and he saw me and he
went hey kid and he threw a bird he
threw a burlap sack to me and i caught
it
and then you know and then i got the
idea no so uh that's a good idea ryan's
gonna be
the idea for the our pillow and this was
basically what you said was it's the
most brutal pillow ever
but it has the right ideology so you
have to buy it
that's basically what they're saying
about static shock and this woke media
the content is garbage but it's the
right ideology so you have to watch it
it's clapter yes you know exactly ever
so you ever see like claptor
yeah where are you guys i know but i
have at my show the clapter so
come raptor the clown yes i got it
i get it guys it's getting late well
it's a pillow
yes we're speaking of getting late
segway yeah we're doing
we're doing our pillow and this is the
first time ryan's actually got too late
on it
how would you rate yeah a scale of one
to ten are you showing it right now oh
no you don't want anything
go grab it if you want do you want to
unveil it wait wait we've already shown
it before
oh yeah it's been so whatever so you got
to you have to yeah so you've got the
new pillow how would you rate it on a
scale of one to ten i liked it i mean
for me it wouldn't be for me but like my
girl i
obviously give i have a separate blanket
and then she's in a burlap sack so that
could be a good idea that makes sense oh
yeah
that could be a good addition the edge
of the bed or the floor uh she would be
on the floor yeah
right outside the door kind of thing
well that's
where else am i what she's gonna be not
when she gets thirsty
don't you think it's a little wasteful
to give just a glorious communist pillow
to somebody
that's a little high class yeah it's
gonna be for you huh yeah
it's gonna be for me you're right so
they're gonna be performatively
expensive you're right she should not
get a pillow
that's true yeah there you go why would
you waste it no she what she'll do is um
girls should all sleep in a woman's
hillary clinton suit jacket with the
hanger still in it hanged up on the rack
that sounds good yeah i could do that do
you write this stuff down just to
use for like later sketches like right
on this thing that's you think i should
have a sketch
that's the sketch like every how every
woman sleeps
i mean i don't mean that one
specifically but you know all right
let's read some more of these things we
gotta
we will read more mitch stu says tim i
am going to resend you my resume and
post it in your subreddit within 24
hours to show my interest in joining
your team
i share your vision and would love to
simply share my ideas also i love you
ryan
you are the future of comedy thank you
very much but notice he didn't call you
the present of comedy
see that was actually a secret firm i
have a video called the future of comedy
so i'm wondering if that's it
pando 56 says ryan need a sketch about
jessica yanev where she runs out of
money and needs to start suing
she targets she's kind of uh out of the
news right now i feel like her moment's
kind of done
yeah tim dillon did a really funny one
about the
the the salons and stuff no the new
the health minister oh right right right
right
it's just so this is not the
you know the craziest thing but so i
have a studio in toronto which i still
have but
um i'm getting rid of it soon oh uncle
pennybags here
and i'm playing dude i'm i'm just i'm my
uh i got a pretty leaky operation going
on here
yeah i got a burlap sink uh holding my
money right now there is
leakage yeah i do not need a studio in
toronto that i can't go to but i'm
subletting some of these things out but
so me and danny were reading about the
jessica yaniv thing or whatever
and while we were talking about the
story in our office that danny's got to
do the sketches with we were like this
is crazy or whatever
and then at the same time we're like
it's crazy that there's all this news
stuff happening outside of our office
blah blah
and at the same time we never realized
it but while we were reading the story
it was happening because it's across the
street from my office the spa where
she went to try to get the the ball
waxing
wow it was across the street from my
office so every day for three days there
was you know
pm canadian tmz there being like what
were the balls like
you know no i don't know but just trying
to get this scoop
so yeah that's pretty crazy right that's
that's that's that's uh
across the street from my office
serendipitous yeah have to
and more so we were like that is pretty
nice to know that there's a ball wax in
place
i mean that's true in the area silver
lining united we stan says is it me or
does luke sound weird tonight his voice
seems higher and really loud too yeah
really loud
wow that changed
all right uh cocoduce has been in the
military for 13 plus years
left ideology over the last decade has
infected current leadership to massive
degrees
i can't remember a time when color
gender and race didn't really matter
now it's the only thing that matters
secession may be the only option
it's a scary prospect man it's a very
scary watching the tv show succession
is the only option forgetting about all
your problems and just
watching kieran culkin do his art
all right let's see darth sarka says oh
my one chance to super chat okay one at
least two anime
discussions and no attack on titan two
well of course
it's i i've watched only a little bit of
attack on titan i'm not good you know
you like it i like the the art yeah i
like i like attack on hill better have
you seen that meme
someone made it you know attack on
titans no it's an anime where there's
like giant monsters that eat people i
guess
and so
somebody made a meme where the titans
are hank are king of the hill characters
and the the like the heroes are like
they have like these things on their on
their waist that like shoot hordes to
like project like prepare themselves
and it's it's hank hill and he's holding
spatulas and attack on hill and
the titan is bill dauterive it's really
good he says uh tim
if i send you this gift will you
pronounce jiff like normal people do
three nazis only have those symbols
because we let them that's true
um the creator of the gif said it was
pronounced jif so
i don't know i've had this conversation
before i've been down to bring it back
so many times
is it gif or jif fight it out biff i
believe it was
talked about pronunciation
but it is though that argument
let's say that you're right that the
creator said that
things do kind of change it's the and
the new one that everyone says it's the
guy that says potato and you go
and you go okay oh you go it's actually
originally pronounced like that and you
go get the hell out of here like
no it's not anymore yeah eric miller
says ryan you should do a follow-up to
the voting wrong
turned me white where the guy sees the
woka cola ad
drinks the coke and it fades to black
and you hear him say i'm back baby
that's pretty funny that's great do you
see you see george alex opolis's uh
comic he made about the woca cola thing
yeah oh wait no i didn't
sorry i seen the coca-cola thing so
george alexander who does this these
paintings we have
okay g-prime85 on social media it's a
white woman
renouncing whiteness and being baptized
in coke
and then she comes up and she's covered
says how dare you sully the name of
bible man
how did he get his powers from the bible
i don't know
lanius shrike says if you think
religious kids shows suck you've
probably never seen
five-ish what is that i've not heard of
that is that good
must be no i've never seen that i've
seen 69-ish guys
oh this guy's way too late for the
that's for the private
spicy spicy is there any good like i
think they're they've made some details
uh christ ones oh passion of the christ
this is a pretty good movie that's not
like you can make
movies with a point without you know
slamming it with propaganda it's just
you need to be bet you need to care more
about
like the making the good things first
and then your ideology is going to be in
there anyway because you have it
all right let's see recto says did you
guys did you guys buy the dip
in crypto five-digit btc what a gift ian
said 50 words on this episode
silenced by big tim lmao what if ian
just randomly screamed in the mic in the
middle of an episode
and then two hours of death glare okay
i mean me and tim are both pretty talky
that's a yeah
all right let's see i did not buy the
dip on crypto however
i have some crypto proxies and my boy
danny paul's chuck who has a
a podcast that he talks about this stuff
he's been buying cr and
selling crypto uh trading cards which is
hilarious to me
so it's essentially crypto cards oh yeah
but they don't exist
except for on the blockchain though or
your physical copy
he's into all sorts of that stuff yeah
the nft stuff the non-fungible tokens
alex grindelin says tim when you lived
in fremont did you ever go to the improv
comedy club there
club there comedy sports maybe when you
lived in seattle it was over in ballard
i did not i did go to a record store
every so often and talk some of the
people there
that was a long time ago so i'm not like
i'm gonna it's like 14 years ago so
i don't know where it was uh
the miami improv did they say there was
no like over in
fremont fremont chicago
uh yeah seattle oh yeah yeah
let's see trip suck says they've ruined
my favorite superhero ryan never change
tim many rebel many liberals just like
me watch this show
your listeners are not only on the right
oh that i know
the i suppose we we did it we did a poll
and found i think the biggest group of
people who watched
my regular youtube content was
libertarian
and then it was like moderate
conservative
followed by liberal and then it was
followed by i can't remember we talked
about it quite a bit but there actually
were social justice warrior like far
leftists like two or three percent of
the people pulled said they watched my
show
yeah and that's where they were and
that's why like i mentioned this
sometimes i went to portland
and actually had some antifa people like
fist bump me and say don't don't let
anybody know like
that's funny yeah it's the world's way
more unified than it seems
uh oh did it jump it jumped
i said uh-oh because someone said uh
bobby bob says tim's parking lot will
never be the same without its hobo
true i'm sad every time i see him uncle
eddie uncle eddie's cousin eddie yeah
from uh so yeah luke luke's on vacation
yeah yeah um it may be permanent because
that dude's basically a vagabond
that's the right word right yeah yeah
like he just travels around
traipses around he lives where he goes
and goes where he lives
except he's got like a big truck and a
mobile and like a an rv so it's actually
pretty nice oh yeah it's fancy traveling
yeah dude it's
super cool it's like a champagne
socialist traveling pretty much yeah
champagne vega bonding yes perfect
what's the book yeah he's he's got jack
kerouac but it's
you know the fancy hard copy all right
mara's exalted says hey crew been
watching every night after work
big fan of the show lids is an
underrated source of info
i'm a canadian music artist and would
love to help out any music endeavors
also have a song called smilet that rap
fans may enjoy
interesting uh you know i have a million
and one songs
if i was to actually write down every
song i've ever written it's probably a
viable complete song several hundred
there's probably thousands of some type
of song with like melodic but not like
written out but we are working on a new
one
which will probably never get done
because all the songs we're originally
working on because we did will of the
people
well we just bounce around too much i
think we'll get this one done though
punk rock for biden
yes yep it is you know uh it's it's a
it's we want it to be it's it's double
punk because
normally punk is supposed to be like
anti-establishment right yeah and so
we're anti
the anti-establishment so it's like
inadvertently pro-biden because we don't
want to conform to the non-conformists
we don't want to hit
so it's it's unironically pro-biden
actually as
a statement against that's what they
call sub-punk
sub-punk um yeah are you a drummer yeah
yeah we should jam next time your time
we just got a kit i think it's on the
way right now
it's half here nice yeah oh it's gonna
be loud halfway you play drums
yeah really yeah so uh and uh
james o'keefe what does he play he sings
he sings
and jack bosobic plays bass yeah oh and
we'll get ryan logan
i think we talked about that i did
jack's thing and he was telling me that
yeah
and we'll and we'll make a super group
and we'll call it the far right
perfect i identify politically as a
comedian
that's right thank you very much ryan
ryan long
labels off of me that's what i say to
girls and that's what i say to you
politics people
there you go fair all right let's see
george d says tim with australia you
have to separate what's going on in
melbourne under dictator dan
and the rest of australia apart from
melbourne we are living life back to
normal no curfew no masks and everything
oh is that
the one i said okay but you have to
understand too when they say
outside of melbourne everybody knows
that you have melbourne and then you
have the outback that's right that's all
australia is
so it's it you live in a city or you
ride kangaroo yep that's
all that's how it works there was a i'm
kidding by the way but there was a
really funny podcast i guess
uh rose byrne who is an uh she's an
australian actress
and it was really funny because so we
had sydney watson on the show
do you know sydney watson is no she's
australian and we did like a whole bonus
segment where we just asked her about
kangaroos
and she was and she was answering it but
then this the segment rose byrne did on
the other podcast she was like i grew up
in a city
i've i've i have no idea what it's like
in the middle of nowhere with these
animals stop
asking me if you ask me i will snap if
you ask me about a kangaroo
and i saw that i started laughing
because we literally were like sydney
tell us about kangaroos yeah
tell us about didgeridoo all right fine
i have three it was really
could you imagine if an australian
person came and said tell us about the
bison
you'd be like i don't know i know i
drove fast one one time it was crazy
they have horns and like apparently you
can get them to eat but if you tell me
like you know some of the canadian
stereotypes like i
yeah you say not animals as much but you
know
whatever hockey syrup like i kind of
stereotypes you know kind of true fresh
maple syrup yeah they exist
have you had have you had fresh maple
syrup from the tree yeah
oh yeah like you have cakes and all that
stuff but we have that here too
though not like right out of there but i
guess we do it yeah yeah absolutely
right out of the trees like that would
be like a school trip would be
a cliche one thing like that where you
go and snowshoe around with your class
or something crap
but that's canadian no no i did that in
illinois we went and like there's maple
trees everywhere illinois is basically
canada
okay i guess yeah
the great lakes separated us yeah yeah i
guess when that when the country
peacefully divorces illinois and new
york are going to join
the united states of canada and then
everyone else jesus christ that's the
meme you know jesus
yeah all right let's see eric wright
says curious about everyone's favorite
animal and a brief explanation including
lydia keep up the great work team ryan
favorite animal a woman i'd say is mine
really interesting intelligent
what if you said human then you're just
done with it i don't know
okay you go first you come back well i
want to talk about i'm going to say the
gorilla
uh and if you if you haven't had a
chance yeah check out this
uh gorilla there it is
ian's favorite animal pick this t-shirt
up on uh i think on timcast.com
and click shop i'm a gorilla it's
actually a monkey but i mean i don't
really sometimes i wonder about the
difference
the monkeys i just like the primates you
know the intelligence in their eyes
yeah they're pretty cool final answers
guys no i guess i don't really have one
but if i had to pick i'd say crows
girls are cool they're serious they're
the top ten smartest animal on the
planet
frozen rats they you can you can speak
english to them
you can teach them things okay yeah it's
it's crazy and
you ever hear the story about the little
girl there oh no a better story there
was a woman
who used to go hiking and taking photos
and she would leave
food for the crows one day she dropped
her her camera lens
cap and when she came home it was laying
on
her her stairs oh my god he brought it
back the crow saw she dropped it picked
it up and brought it to her house and
left it for her
there was they were doing i don't know
if you heard about on the set of the
crow
um yeah i did yeah brandon lee man tried
your story
no no that was another thing that
dropped there was uh
geez dude no i was just saying one of
the grips
was a rapper so he dropped like super
that's right that's right honestly had
nothing to do with uh there was
there were some researchers i think they
were at syracuse and they would capture
crows to use in research
and they learned that if you if you
engage in this you have to wear a mask
because the crows would never forget
yeah you were the one who captured them
and subjected them to experiments
so they would and they would tell their
friends and they would like poop on
people and like harass them no joke
crows are legit smart there was a guy
who invented a crow vending machine
brilliant he basically set up this
machine where there was a plate
like an attachment full of cover covered
in food put the money in and get a crow
well the crow would land on it they
would eat the food and then crows sweep
the ground when there's no food left and
they knocked the coins into the machine
which made more nuts come out yeah then
he put coins on the ground and so when
the coin when the coins were gone the
crows would jump down grab the coins
flap and put them in the machine and get
nuts
once that was gone they would fly around
the neighborhood looking for loose
change
wow bring them back and he said his like
profit his total profit was going to be
in this
like somewhere in like 86 cents oh my
god but
wow he was effectively he effectively
trained the crows to find money for him
yeah yeah that's that's that's amazing
it's better than buying a metal detector
that's awesome i love it it is
uh so ryan what's your favorite animal
okay my favorite animal
is sloth
those are cool how about a sloth i did a
report on
their defense mechanism is basically
just not moving yeah and i like that
they're kind of the bad boy because
everyone trashes them like oh what do
you mean everybody loves you
no it's like lazy slime yeah
two toed or three three-toed or is it
three-toed or four-toed
how about three yeah three totes long
we have it right hold on riveting stuff
here we got a bunch of guys we got a
bunch of important information
56th crusader says bible man got his
powers from his obedience to god
they gave him a robin-esque sidekick in
the second or third episode not as good
as angel wars in my opinion
interesting and carnacle blackburn says
bible man's lightsaber is powered by
faith
i loved him and veg veggie tales growing
up also
three two one penguins kevin is goat
bible man
is so bad it's good i want to watch
bible man i liked veggie tales i want to
watch it yeah i'll check it out
yeah i'll definitely watch bible man
sure it's gonna be like i bet you could
take bible man and the new black lives
matter
static shock and be like i see
similarities and how it's like all about
ideology
yeah he's like the police were tear
gassing me because i was doing the right
thing
now i have power baby kobe lost his
power if you stop believing in the right
you know
doing the right thing i mean that's
probably going to happen someone's going
to be like
you know what i think it's really
happening to be honest there's probably
a bunch of young woke people
and there's like checked out gen xers
who are sitting there with their eyes
half closed
and then the person's like i got an idea
he said he he a black lives matter
protest he gets his powers and the boss
is just like
oh yeah you know whatever we're going to
sell so you know what that
is the trick that they're all like a lot
of these things they're missing and i
watched
because i see movies that do this kind
of stuff and they're fine
and you ever watch a conversation and
they like you're kind of you have an
argument
and they're not addressing like the
other side you're like no that's not
what they think you know what kind of
thing
right where it's the same thing when
this where they treat other people like
not humans like i watched there was this
one the camera was called but they had a
it was like a black dude he got out of
jail and the cops were
kind of the enemies and they'd killed a
guy but then they also showed
the cop what he looks like as a human so
he went back and
basically he felt he like you know felt
like in
he didn't know what to do and he kind of
was going through and his wife was
leaving him and this guy's life sucked
and then they showed
the the third person which was the
friend and his girlfriend they kind of
they humanized they're able to humanize
the other side i was i was very like
um and i think that in comedy so many
times they write other people right now
like they hate them and you can't write
people like you hate them so that's why
people's trump's impressions were so bad
because it's just i'm a freaking idiot
yeah it's like
yeah like family guys trump episode it
was just they made him
tiny hands with a bright orange face and
it was like dude on the nose
just a little much of a character but
yeah that's not really
you know there's funny parts about
everyone but you need to like contain
the humanity and i think it's
when you're providing the opposite side
same as providing the opposite
perspective it's like
every even in most superheroes it's like
they're villains not just all bad
like something got them there and you
sort of see their stuff that's how i
feel about hitler i can tell you more
about it in the bonus section
don't get into your theory you you so
understand the villain all right with
these stories i think about a lot when
when i'm like writing music you can't
just tell
the audience what's happening you have
to like
allow their imagination to guide them to
some capacity you can't write a song
where you're just literally
so i wrote the people and it's telling a
story but a lot of it you can't see
unless you watch the video
and so you know i'm talking to nish
today because i'm writing the song and
she was like there's a lot of
information to convey in this that we
can't get in lyrics and i was like
that's like kind of the point
if you go to the new school where it's
people kind of like look if you look at
lonely island they were writing songs
knowing that the video was gonna be part
of the eggs and i think that a lot of
people are doing that musically right
now where they're sort of picturing the
video to convey something else while
they're writing it
the song will be good but with the video
you really understand it
that's true for will of the people you
don't want them to be like that guy that
villain is so evil you just want the
audience to see the villain's behavior
and
think wow that's very you want the
audience to think it to realize it on
there i mean
you know you guys are saying what you
said hold on you know it's crazy to me
i guess this is a relatively new thing
in comics
i shouldn't say relatively new it's been
some time but like uh the origin of mr
freeze and the batman animated series do
you guys know this
no they won an emmy i think it was the
first cartoon to ever win an emmy i
think it was an emmy i'm not sure
but uh mr freeze originally comic book
villains were like one dimensional
i'm going to take over the world because
i'm evil mr freeze was his wife was
terminally ill
and he was misappropriating corporate
funds to do research to try and cure her
disease
and when the boss found out he was like
how dare you shut it down
and then then while they were fighting
he was like no i won't let you kill my
wife and he grabs a gun
and then the security guy throws him
down and then the cryogenic chemicals
blast him and then he gets turned into
mr freeze
and his whole motivation is he's trying
to save his wife's life
and it's all about his own personal
selfishness so it was like
it was an interesting backstory for a
villain like magneto also was kind of
like yeah
and doctor doom i think magneto later on
i don't think i think originally magneto
was
really one-dimensional and then it was
later artists who really made this
amazing like x-men's
genius stuff and it's social justice
stuff this is the crazy thing
you know x-men is social justice magneto
was
in a polish concert he was in a
concentration camp in poland and
they were in some some of the artists uh
comic book writings of x-men
is that magneto is like malcolm x and
professor x is like dr king
where professor x is very much like
through peace and reform we will bring
about
unity and magneto it's tropin a million
things it's you know the piece of
form versus the you know the i mean the
black panther was kind of right
yeah so it used to be the villains were
just like i'm evil
and then later on they started
developing villains to actually have
legitimate motivations and then now
they are taking now they're devolving
where the protagonists
are just one dimensional no no but it's
not even that the police in the static
shock thing it's like
get out of here or we're going to tear
gas you for no reason pew pew like wait
what
come on like what's that show homeland
homelander is that what it's called
whether it's like
boys the boys i think they took it too
far
because those are like overtly
villainous heroes
though i like heroes that are corrupt or
have a have a weakness or like a you
know you need that otherwise it's not a
real
yeah well it went into like the campy
world yeah it got way out there yeah
but there is something cool about
the flawed superhero that is a human
yeah
all right we're gonna do one more super
chat it is
what is this gu bazooka pangolins are
the coolest animals they're very cool
that's right oh wait wait i'm sorry
there's one more scott gosnell says
i live in oklahoma when someone asks me
about buffaloes i just say that their
wings taste like chicken
ah ladies and gentlemen thank you so
much for hanging out
make sure you uh come back we're live
monday through friday at 8 p.m
go to timcast.com because in about an
hour we should have the
members exclusive segments will be up
then
and you can follow me on all social
media at tim cast my other youtube
channels are youtube.comtimcast and
youtube.comcastnews
if you really like this show consider
sharing it because i had a really fun i
had a funny uh conv
i was having a conversation today and
the guy said people find out about
podcasts from people who listen to
podcasts so it's like
the only real way we make the show
bigger and better and
and grow is if the people who watch it
tell other people to watch it
so if you like it by all means sharing
is the best thing you can do
but uh subscribe and smash that like
button you want to mention anything ryan
before we dip out to exclusive members
only stuff
also while you're sharing the podcast
you're already there you've got your
finger on the dial
ryan long comedy on youtube patreon.com
the boyscast which is also my podcast
the boys cast
lots of dates coming up soon and um the
main ones everything's at ryan long
comedy including my website but we're
gonna be
for anyone that's watching right now
we're going to um uh
florida and we're doing tampa in orlando
in march
you can also follow my uh my network at
ian crossland.net where you can
purchase some uh paraphernalia yeah read
the code
free the code baby yeah as well as uh
donate if you'd like to support the
cause
and the movement of me uh but yeah have
some fun
the battle movement it's so great to
have you here brother um thanks you guys
and then there's me in the corner i'm
sour patch lids on twitter
and mines and then i'm real sour patch
lids on
gab and instagram we will see you all
over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you